[Musique]
bonjour à tous très heureux de vous
retrouver sur Public Sénat pour une
nouvelle semaine d'examen de la réforme
des retraites ici à la Haute Assemblée
toute cette semaine vous pourrez suivre
en direct les échanges des sénateurs sur
notre antenne dans le cadre de nos
émissions spéciales et puis également
sur notre site internet publique.fr avec
de très bons articles de décryptage on
va tout de suite aller en séance dans
l'hémicycle du Sénat les sénateurs vont
débattre d'une proposition de la droite
de création d'un CDI senior pour inciter
les entreprises à embaucher des seniors
et on commentera à ses débats avec
Quentin Calmet toute la journée c'est
parti pour une nouvelle semaine de débat
sur la réforme des retraites au Sénat
pour 2023 dans un parvenu à l'amendement
2112 rectifié qui tente à insérer
l'article additionnel après l'article 2
rappelle le règlement madame rossignol
au règlement se font de sur les articles
8 du préambule de 46 et 55 de la
Constitution il concerne donc chacun
leur a compris l'exercice du droit de
grève en France de
le monsieur le ministre vous appliquez
la règle du 30e indivisible c'est-à-dire
que en ce qui concerne les
fonctionnaires d'État pour deux heures
de grève il leur est retiré une journée
de salaire cette règle est une règle
spécifiquement appliquée au
fonctionnaire de la fonction publique
d'État puisqu'elle n'est pas appliquée
dans ces termes-là ni au fonctionnaire
de la fonction publique hospitalière ni
au sud ni à ceux de la fonction publique
territoriale or il se trouve que le
Conseil de l'Europe a été chargé
d'examiner la compatibilité le respect
par cette règle du droit de grève qui
est garantie par l'achat social
européenne et il a rendu sa décision il
y a quelques jours et cette décision est
très claire la règle du 30e indivisible
viol l'article 6 paragraphe 4 de la
Charte sociale européenne donc monsieur
le ministre comptez-vous mettre fin à
cette règle discriminatoire
discriminatoire entre les différents
fonctionnaires d'une part et
discriminatoire à l'encontre des
salariés de la fonction publique qui use
de l'endroit de grève je vous pose cette
question aujourd'hui parce qu'elle est
particulièrement importante la veille
d'un mouvement social qui à la fois va
être très fort contre votre réforme et
qui en même temps se situe dans un
contexte particulier qui est celui d'une
inflation importante et de pression
forte sur le pouvoir d'achat donc
monsieur le ministre je comprends bien
l'intérêt vicieux qu'il pourrait y avoir
à compter sur les difficultés
financières des fonctionnaires pour
espérer qu'il renonce à exercer
l'endroit de grève demain mais je
n'imagine pas que le gouvernement puisse
se livrer à un calcul aussi sordide donc
il serait bon que aujourd'hui vous
annoncez au fonctionnaires que ceux qui
feront grève quelques heures demain ne
se verront pas retirer la totalité de
leur journée de travail mais simplement
leurs heures de grève
acte est donné de ce rappel au règlement
nous allons examiner un amendement essai
de sous un amendement qui vont faire
l'objet d'une discussion
commune
un amendement
2112 rectifié
monsieur rapporteur
bien merci monsieur le Président on
attaque dans le vif du sujet en ce qui
concerne notre stratégie d'emploi des
seniors là
cet amendement porte sur les seniors au
chômage 2 milliard quatre consacrés par
lunédique pour les chômeurs de plus de
60 ans ça doit quelque part nous
interpeller donc ce qui veut dire que
les outils actuels d'emploi des seniors
ne sont pas suffisants c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons sur proposition
de longues de partenaires sociaux
proposés ce CDI senior le CDI senior
c'est quoi c'est un CDI différent
réservé un contrat entre le salarié et
son employeur pour que on définisse les
conditions de travail le les durées de
travail pour aller jusqu'au taux plein
de départ en retraite du salarié le taux
plein voulant dire être acquis à la fois
par les nombres de trimestres ou
éventuellement avec l'âge d'annulation
de la décote c'est tout à fait différent
de ce qui existe actuellement puisque
les CDI classique peuvent toujours être
utilisés mais sont pas suffisants
puisque on constate que il y a
effectivement un taux de chômage aux
alentours de la soixantaine qui est
particulièrement important c'est pour ça
qu'on veut se doter d'outils nouveaux
pour inciter pour inciter l'employeur
nous proposons une exonération de
cotisation familiales de façon à ce
qu'il y ait une incitation à aller
plutôt sur ce CDI très spécifique
négocié avec le salarié par rapport à
ces traditionnel et pour le salarié ça
me paraît intéressant puisque on adapte
les conditions de travail en fonction
effectivement de son âge ou des
phénomènes d'usure c'est la raison pour
laquelle ce CDI peut être dès à présent
me semble-t-il inscrit dans la loi et je
ne vous demande de le soutenir de façon
à ce qu'ensuite et c'est notre
préoccupation il soit discuté avec les
partenaires sociaux dans le cadre des
négociations pour qu'il puisse être
adopté prise en main par les partenaires
sociaux je vous remercie
sous abondement madame Lubin que vous
présentez
oui merci monsieur le Président en fait
nous aurions fait nous comprenons bien
l'objectif de de cette proposition de
notre de notre rapporteur
mais il y a un certain nombre de choses
sur lesquelles nous ne sommes pas
d'accord sur le contenu de ce contrat je
pense que nous aurons l'occasion d'en
débattre avec monsieur le rapporteur qui
nous apportera
ses réponses en attendant nous avons
souhaité poser un
amendement qui propose juste certes de
remplacer les mots dernière fin de
carrière par dernière embauche mais ça
peut paraître anodin mais ça ne l'est
pas c'est parce qu'en fait dans ce qui
est proposé ce qui nous dérange par
exemple c'est la possibilité à un
employeur de mettre fin au contrat de
travail dès que si j'ai bien compris le
salarié atteindrait la possibilité le
niveau auquel il devrait il pourrait
valider sa retraite et ça ça nous ça
nous paraît sous couvert d'une
proposition je le sais
qui est sincère ça nous paraît pouvoir
être comment dire un outil
supplémentaire pour des employeurs de
recruter des gens qu'on garde finalement
le moins longtemps possible mais on aura
l'occasion d'en discuter merci monsieur
le Président
Monsieur Dufour le présent
le président de mes chers collègues il
est proposé un certain amendement de
pour les mesures de signative à l'emploi
de remettre l'argent 55 ans au lieu de
60 tels que prévu par le texte
monsieur Hainaut présente
2343 oui merci monsieur le Président si
vous le voulez bien je vais évoquer les
deux dans la même argumentation parce
qu'ils sont très très proches et il se
suivent monsieur les ministres
je vais pas reprendre l'argumentation du
rapporteur je pense que nous sommes tous
d'accord pour dire que l'emploi des
seniors est un défi pour notre société
c'est aussi une question à résoudre si
on veut équilibrer notre système de
répartition et bien évidemment que ce
soit sur le plan économique financier et
surtout morale ça ne peut pas être la
variable d'ajustement des des
entreprises notre interrogation elle est
sur la bardage puisque même dans votre
argumentation hier monsieur le
rapporteur vous évoquait les vous
évoquez les 55 74 ans ou le 57
64 ans est-ce que la barre pertinente et
60 ans nous voulons lancer le débat sur
l'idée que ça pourrait être 57 ans et
qui pourrait y avoir une disposition
progressive
25% d'exonération puis 5 ans puis 75 et
puis 100 % voilà nous vous souhaitons ce
débat sur l'âge pertinent pour ce CDI
senior mais bien évidemment nous
partageons l'idée nous pensons qu'elle
est tout à fait pertinente je vous
remercie merci le sous-amendement
4742 madame Lubin
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
donc nous sommes opposés c'est ça
revient à ce que je disais tout à
l'heure à ce contrat dernière embauche
parce que il peut donner lieu à la mise
à la retraite d'office avant 70
oui c'est ça ce qu'il peut donner lieu à
la mise à la retraite d'office avant 70
ans je sais pas qui ça fait rire mais
bon voilà
comme pour le reste des des salariés
4743 on considère comme défendu par la
même métal esprit
oui
en est-il de même pour le 4744
c'est un amendement extrêmement
important qui pense qui porte sur la
question des exonérations de cotisation
sociale c'est une discussion qu'on a
souvent eu dans cette émission qu'on a
régulièrement à l'occasion du PLFSS oui
on l'a à l'occasion du pfss d'ailleurs
j'avais déposé un amendement qui
prévoyait de supprimer une exonération
de cotisations sociales sur les
cotisations d'allocations familiales
justement pour les salariés
rémunéré plus de 1,6 fois le SMIC pardon
c'est pas exactement 1,6 et dont le
Conseil d'analyses économique avait
pointé que cet exonération était sans
effet sur l'emploi donc inutile sauf à
vouloir faire des exonérations pour
faire des exonérations on avait eu un
débat intéressant dans l'hémicycle un
vote je vous rappelle qu'il avait vu
faire un acide-boue comme quoi comme
quoi la réflexion et j'en suis heureux
s'étend au-delà de nos bancs sur cette
question des exonérations de cotisation
et là il est proposé dans ce contrat ce
nouveau contrat senior de procéder à une
exonération certes que des cotisations
familles mais tout de même d'une partie
exonération ça fait aussi à ce qui avait
été décidé au Père FSS je me rappelle
sur les médecins qu'on allait inciter à
continuer leur activité mais on les
exonération les exonérantes cotisations
sociales alors ces exonérations n'ont
pas de sens le travail produit de la
cotisation il faut maintenir ses
cotisations qui financent écosystème de
protection sociale donc sauf avoir une
idéologie de l'exonération quoi qu'il en
coûte et bien si on défend un système
juste de répartition fondée sur la
cotisation il faut maintenir pour tous
ceux qui sont éligibles à ce contrat
l'ensemble des cotisations sociales
c'est l'objet de cet amendement je vous
remercie monsieur le Président est-ce
que je considère que l'ensemble des sous
amendements présentés par le groupe
socialiste ont été défendus madame Lubin
non
44 le 44
depuis un moment
excusez-moi monsieur le président
non je défends le 44 ou on est d'accord
me perturber pas derrière oui c'est
amendement une vise à supprimer les
alinéa 11 et 12 parce que en fait il
porte sur les allocations familiales et
c'est quand même un sujet qui
régulièrement revient de manière feutrée
ou incidente dans nos débats à la
commission des affaires sociales mais
aussi dans d'autres débats quelle
politique familiale il se trouve que je
considère que la question démographiques
sont des vrais sujets d'ailleurs je n'ai
toujours pas compris quelle est la
politique démographique de ce
gouvernement ni à la garde ni à l'égard
de la transition démographique
c'est-à-dire l'augmentation du nombre de
personnes âgées ni d'ailleurs à l'égard
de la politique familiale et qu'elle est
aujourd'hui ce que ce gouvernement veut
offrir proposer aux familles à toutes
les familles de façon à ce que les
conditions d'accueil des jeunes enfants
soit les meilleurs or il y a là petite
ambiguïté voire même une contradiction
pour moi vous êtes souvent mes chers
collègues de droite offensif sur les
allocations familiales sur la politique
nataliste n'est pas exactement mon sujet
et sur les moyens que nous devons y
consacrer et pour cela
vous êtes prêts malgré cela vous êtes
prêt à supprimer pour le contrat dernier
embauche une part des cotisations à
location familiales qui pèse aujourd'hui
sur les employeurs donc je vous appelle
simplement par cet amendement avec mes
collègues à être cohérent entre d'une
part votre vision de la politique
familiale et d'autre part votre vision
des moyens d'accroître l'emploi des
seniors merci alors vainqueur nous
allons demander l'avis de la commission
sur l'ensemble des sous amendements
je suis le rapporteur
oui merci monsieur le Président j'ai
deux minutes par sous amendement je suis
pas obligé de les utiliser rassurez-vous
monsieur le Président mais ça nécessite
quand même des précisions un nous avons
pas parlé du coup pas d'histoire
d'argent monsieur le ministre entre nous
cependant il y a des répercussions
effectivement et vous avez annoncé à ce
titre là un coup de 800 millions d'euros
qu'aurait ce contrat là parce que vous
pensez que il y aura un effet d'aubaine
et que les employeurs vont pas discerner
la différence entre le CDI classique et
le CDI senior qui est différent alors
effectivement on arrive et je confirme
je confirme c'est c'est 800 millions
d'euros mais je pense que le CDI senior
s'est autre chose et s'il y a des
exonérations on peut les estimer plus on
les estime ces exonérations de façon
importante plus plus le bénéfice est
important pour l'ensemble de la société
car si on fait des exonérations à un
coup de prohibitif ça veut dire que
derrière
les cotisations familiales s'entre 30 et
5 entre 3 et 5% sur 40% de cotisations
salariale et patronales donc si vous
perdez pour le budget de l'État ou de la
sécurité sociale 3 à 5 % et que vous
gagnez 40 - 3 5 35 à 37 %, c'est tout
bénef et pendant que votre Seigneur est
employé dans un cadre particulier de ce
CDI senior avec un accompagnement et
bien il n'est pas au chômage et le
chômage on sait que ça coûte cher donc
l'intérêt pour la société pour les
comptes de l'État pour les contes de la
sécurité sociale c'est que ce dispositif
enfin marche parce qu'on en a déjà
essayé beaucoup et ça n'a pas toujours
marché il n'empêche que si nous avons
une vision différente contre l'emploi
des seniors il faut se douter d'outils
nouveaux donc je lance effectivement
cette piste là et c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont définir par branche
quels sont les branches intéressées si
des branches ne sont pas intéressées et
bien il y a pas de voilà si des branches
sont intéressées et bien elle
définissent qu'elle doit être les
conditions de négociation entre le
salariale employeur quant à cet
accompagnement jusqu'à l'âge légal et
c'est comme les contrats chantiers quand
vous construisez un collège et il y a
des présidents de départements qui sont
là quand vous le construisez un collège
ça dure entre 3 5 7 ans parfois plus et
en conséquence quand vous embauchez des
personnes vous prenez un CDI chantier de
la durée du chantier là c'est la durée
de la fin de carrière merci monsieur le
Président mais je tenais à présenter ces
précisions maintenant je réponds sous
amendements parce que c'est tout à fait
important
madame Lubin propose
d'appeler ça contrat de dernier embauche
je crois qu'on aille mis un avis
défavorable à la commission mais
franchement si ça peut nous réunir qu'on
appelle contrat senior ou dernier
embauche ça correspond à ça ça peut être
l'intitulé de dernier embauche donc là
aussi les partenaires sociaux définiront
la façon dont ils veulent l'appeler
franchement j'ai aucun état d'âme
là-dessus mais ça rejoint notre
préoccupation parce que c'est celle que
nous avions définies lors lors du
rapport que nous avions fait sur
l'emploi des seniors donc c'est tout à
fait important en ce qui concerne
Olivier nos Olivier Hainaut nous propose
effectivement de déterminer un âge
différent alors déjà monsieur le
ministre des comptes sociaux et des
comptes de l'État nous disent que ça
coûte cher à 60 ans Alors j'ai pas osé
franchement
envisagé qu'on puisse le mettre à partir
de 55 ans bien entendu ce seront des
partenaires sociaux qui selon les
branches nous dirons quel âge il faut
mettre vous voyez ça n'a justement c'est
pas d'ici de niveau du Parlement qu'on
va définir tout cela on a véritablement
une négociation qui peut s'instaurer par
branche et peut-être que on peut
comprendre que c'est un âge différent
selon le type de métier à mesure la
pénibilité on aura l'occasion de le
définir c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai mis un avis défavorable en ce qui
concerne effectivement
je crois que c'est
je ne sais plus qui excusez-moi non
c'est aussi Monique Monique Lubin
jusque 70 ans oui 70 ans c'est le seuil
c'est toi je crois 70 ans c'est le seuil
actuel
d'emploi où on peut effectivement
définir une rupture
unilatérale demandée par l'employeur
pour mise à la retraite avec des
conditions bien spécifiques en ce qui
concerne les cotisations le forfait
social qui est adapté à ce type de
prestation avant 70 ans si l'employeur
ne souhaite rompre avec son employé sa
dispositif de licenciement classique ou
une rupture conventionnelle
c'est un frein il faut bien reconnaître
aujourd'hui savoir quand vous avez des
seniors qui peuvent rester jusqu'à 70
ans parce que ça dépend du salarié quand
il peut partir à la retraite il prévient
je pars à la retraite sauf que s'il ne
veut pas partir à la traite
effectivement nombre d'entreprises nous
disent on est contraint de par la loi de
les garder jusqu'à 70 ans et en
conséquence en conséquence ça peut poser
un problème quand vous embauchez un
seigneur vers 60 60 ans
ça fera l'emploi et beaucoup
d'entreprises
hésitent parce que
voyez-vous on peut comprendre que donc
c'est la raison pour laquelle il faut un
contrat spécifique incitatif pour rompre
ce frein à l'emploi parce que compte
tenu de la longévité faut vraiment qu'il
y ait cette prise de conscience et pour
que elle soit véritablement collective
et ben donnons des outils pour aider à
prendre conscience que les seniors ça va
effectivement contenu de la longévidée
peut-être travailler un peu plus
longtemps en tout cas il faut que ça
puisse être ainsi si on veut éviter de
les mettre dans le dispositif chômage et
trop souvent de la précarité en ce qui
concerne les exonérations
pour lequel on a eu deux remarques
particulières oui nous sommes pas fans
des exonérations et mais cependant
cependant cependant
exonération familiale la branche famille
Laurence Rossignol oui
nous voulons et nous allons l'affirmer à
travers la surcotisation que nous
proposerons pour les maires de famille
qui ont une majoration dès l'instant où
elles ont eu l'âge du taux plein avoir
un ange légal etc donc cette majoration
nous y tenons mais c'est la contrainte
d'un PLFSS si je propose moi je vais
proposer à titre personnel une
exonération chômage ça me paraît
tellement logique puisque vous avez un
contrat qui fait que vous engagez de
garder jusqu'à la retraite votre salarié
donc il n'ira pas dans la cage chômage
en conséquence ce serait légitime qui
est une exonération de la cotisation
chômage là aussi c'est les partenaires
sociaux qui vont le dire ou à travers
une loi travail que vous pourrez lui
proposer on ne peut pas dans le cas du
PLFSS puisque je vous rappelle mais vous
le savez bien vous tous que les contes
lunéiques ne rentrent pas dans le cas du
pérfss
contrairement à ce que nous
contrairement merci madame la Présidente
contrairement à ce que nous demandions
rappelez-vous nous pensions que nous
pourrions avoir un regard voyez ça nous
est le permis de voir les choses un
petit peu différemment mais les
exonérations mes chers collègues
on peut se les permettre quand on a une
assiette assez importante pour les
cotisations la France ne produit pas
assez c'est bien notre difficulté c'est
pour ça que nous avons une base agence
commerciale négative il faut élargir la
base de cotisations et cette réforme va
dans ce sens-là et à ce moment-là si
vous avez élargi votre base de
cotisation les exonérations prennent une
dimension tout à fait différente
je pense avoir répondu à toutes les
interrogations qui a été traduite à
travers tous ces amendements merci alors
la vie du gouvernement à la fois sur
l'amendement de Monsieur Savary
madame douanou au nom de la commission
sociale
et puis sur les sous amendements merci
monsieur le président madame la
présidente de la commission des affaires
sociales Monsieur et Madame et Monsieur
les rapporteurs mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous sommes venus à deux
avec mon collègue mises élégant compte
public pour tenter de résister aux
assauts de monsieur le rapporteur et de
la commission des affaires sociales donc
si vous voulez bien me suivre le
Président je répondrai sur les aspects
qui relèvent du code du travail et
peut-être que mon collègue pourra
répondre sur le la partie du coup
concernant ce contrat nous avons à ce
stade trois interrogations deux attentes
et une crainte que je partage avec vous
les trois interrogations quant à la mise
en oeuvre du contrat proposé par la
Commission des affaires sociales
concerne d'une part le principe
d'égalité avec la difficulté lorsqu'on
crée des bornes d'âge sur l'accès à une
contrat de travail d'une nature
spécifique le risque qu'il y ait des
effets de seuil des effets d'aubaine et
des effets de distorsion la deuxième
interrogation concerne le le ciblage de
cet outil et nous souhaiterions voir
s'il est possible d'aller vers un
ciblage en termes de bénéficiaires
concernant plutôt les demandeurs
d'emploi que l'ensemble des seniors pour
éviter prévenir toute forme d'effets
d'aubaines et puis évidemment nous
souhaitons puisque j'ai évoqué ce terme
d'effet de Ben veillez à ce que la
différence entre le CDI droit commun et
ce nouvel outil qui pourrait s'adresser
au Seigneur soit une différence
particulièrement marquée je donne bien
volontiers actes sur le rapporteur d'un
certain nombre de discussions de
modifications notamment dans la
rédaction de l'amendement pour envoyer
une concertation avec les partenaires
sociaux puisque nous considérons et
c'est là l'occasion pour moi de venir
sur les deux points qui sont des
attentes que le gouvernement exprime à
cette occasion nous considérons qu'il y
aurait d'une part un intérêt à ce que
cette mesure soit créée de nature avec
nature dans un premier temps
expérimental et d'autre part nous
considérons que ce CDI propre senior
relève d'un article que monsieur le
Président du Sénat connais bien
l'article la partie dite L1 du code du
travail et qui cela doit renvoyer à une
concertation interprofessionnelle là où
nous avons encore un écart dans la
rédaction la préparation de ce
dispositif avec monsieur le rapporteur
c'est que le gouvernement considère
qu'il y aurait lieu de renvoyer la
totalité des paramètres et de la
définition du nouveau contrat un décret
faisant suite à une concertation
interprofessionnelle alors que la
rédaction de l'amendement prévoit à ce
stade une écriture plus précise sans
toutefois exonérer le gouvernement d'une
obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle selon ce sont là
les trois points que je voulais
souligner d'une part des interrogations
d'autre part le fait que nous donnons
bien évidemment acte un monsieur
rapporteur et la commission qu'un
certain nombre de modifications allant
dans le bon sens sont déjà intervenus et
enfin deux points d'attente sur le
caractère expérimental et sur
l'articulation avec le L1 du Code du
travail que je voulais souligner je le
fais monsieur le Président en ayant bien
en tête et monsieur le rapporteur que
lorsque l'article du Code du travail
concernant l'obligation de concertation
interprofessionnelle
a été intégré au code du travail je
crois en 2003 ou 2004 2004 il me semble
sous votre autorité il avait été
explicitement prévu que cette obligation
de concertation interprofessionnelle ne
concernait ni les propositions de loi ni
les amendements je crois que l'esprit et
je crois aussi que c'est partagé que
l'esprit prévaut et que il est utile
d'avoir une concertation
interprofessionnelle sur ces sujets là
voilà les remarques qui m'amènent à dire
qu'à à ce stade et en fonction de la
rédaction qui est proposé à cet instant
au Sénat la vie du gouvernement ne peut
pas être favorable et donc par
conséquence il est il est défavorable
mais avec l'espoir que les discussions
et je l'espère les débats que nous
aurons encore cette semaine et ensuite
dans la perspective de la prolongation
du débat parlementaire autour de ce
texte nous puissions trouver un terrain
d'entente monsieur le ministre Attal
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs et sénatrice et sénateur moi
je vous remercie de mettre ce sujet là
sur la table puisque je crois qu'on
cherche tous à réduire le chômage chez
les seniors et à ce titre c'est toujours
intéressant évidemment de discuter des
pistes qui sont proposées moi je suis
toujours assez sceptique sur des
propositions d'allègement de cotisation
ciblées sur un nage donné aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas d'allègement de cotisations
liées à un âge il y a des allègements de
cotisations qui sont liés à un type de
contrats qui sont liés à une
rémunération non les jeunes monsieur
Husson on parle d'allègement sur les
jeunes parce que il y a des allègements
qui sont ciblés sur les niveaux de
salaire au SMIC et que c'est
principalement des jeunes qui sont au
SMIC mais vous n'avez pas de vous n'avez
pas d'allaagement de cotisation lié à un
âge pour une bonne raison à mon avis
c'est que le risque c'est qu'il y a des
effets de seuil
si vous dites il y a un allègement de
cotisation pour l'employeur à partir de
60 ans qu'est-ce qui va se passer pour
les gens qui ont 58 59 ans qui se
présentent dans une entreprise pour être
recruté on va leur dire vous ne coûtez
plus cher que ce que vous ne coûterait à
60 ans donc attendez attendez un an ou
deux ans revenez me voir dans un an ou
dans deux ans quand j'aurai droit à une
exonération de cotisation parce que vous
avez plus de 60 ans donc le risque c'est
qu'on décale le problème et que c'est
que des personnes qui aujourd'hui en
plus 60 ans et sont au chômage en fait
on décale le problème à ceux qui sont
juste avant 60 ans parce que eux
n'auront pas droit à l'exonération pour
leur employeur s'ils sont recrutés ça
c'est la première chose sur la deuxième
chose c'est un amendement qui coûte
effectivement
une certaine somme le chiffre de 800
millions d'euros c'est 800 millions
d'euros si les recrutements actuels
au-delà de 60 ans se font avec le CDI
senior on parle d'effet d'auben c'est à
dire que aujourd'hui vous avez
aujourd'hui vous avez en moyenne 100 000
CDI qui sont signés pour des personnes
qui ont plus de 60 ans par an
si désormais tous ces CDI signés pour
des personnes qui ont plus de 60 ans
chaque année sont faits avec le nouveau
contrat bah non bah en même temps vous
vous prenez vous mettez à la place d'un
employeur vous dites il y a un nouveau
contrat CDI senior qui existe avec moins
de cotisation il va plutôt choisir
celui-là aujourd'hui vous avez 100000
personnes qui sont recrutées en CDI
après 60 ans si désormais ils sont tous
recrutés avec ce nouveau CDI ça coûte
800 millions d'euros pour la branche
famille et ça veut dire que la branche
famille se retrouve déficitaire dès
l'année 2025 or j'entends sur tous les
bancs une volonté d'avoir une politique
familiale ambitieuse pour notamment
inciter à la natalité dans notre pays je
rejoins cet objectif mais donc là on se
retrouve à dépouiller la branche famille
si on va encore plus loin sur l'effet
d'aubaine ça veut dire si toutes les
personnes qui sont actuellement en
emploi en CDI de plus de 60 ans
l'employeur se dit en fait j'ai un
allègement de cotisation qui change de
CDI donc on va toutes les basculer en
CDI senior là ça coûte 2 milliards 300
millions d'euros je dis pas qu'on ira
jusque là monsieur le rapporteur
évidemment
mais en tout cas ça veut dire que si
toutes les personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui en CDI au-delà de 60 ans
elles sont basculées dans un contrat CDI
seniors ça ferait ça ferait ce coup-là
j'entends que vous souhaitez et
notamment dans la discussion avec les
partenaires sociaux qui est des
garde-fous pour qu'ils puissent pas y
avoir tous ces effets d'aubaine mais en
tout cas le fait est que sur les 100000
recrutement qui a chaque année après 60
ans s'ils sont tous recrutés au CDI
seniors et encore une fois vous mettez à
la place de l'employeur il y a une
baisse de cotisation va plutôt le faire
deuxième chose deuxième chose c'est un
dispositif qui va plutôt favoriser les
hauts revenus les hauts salaires ceux
pour les CE pour qui la question des
cotisations n'est pas l'élément
déterminant pour les employeurs si je
vous donne quelques chiffres pour un
salarié qui a un une rémunération de
4500 euros aujourd'hui vous aurez un
effet maximal de baisse de cotisation
alors même que pour un senior qui a une
rémunération autour de 2000 2500 euros
il y a déjà des allègements de
cotisation notamment avec le bandeau
famille et donc l'effet incitatif serait
le plus fort pour des salariés qui ont
les plus hautes rémunérations pour
lesquelles a priori l'incitation sur les
cotisations n'est pas l'élément
déterminant pour leur recrutement donc
c'est au moins 800 millions d'euros de
coûts pour des salariés et des seniors
donc a priori il y a pas le son pour
lesquels il y a le plus besoin d'un
effet incitatif sur les cotisations donc
moi encore une fois j'arrête sur ce
sujet là il y a des dispositifs un peu
semblables qui ont été testés au niveau
européen et un rapport très intéressant
de France stratégie de 2017 qui dit que
ces dispositifs d'exonération
d'allègement de cotisations ciblées sur
les seniors dans les pays qui l'ont
essayé c'est à dire la Finlande la Suède
et la Hongrie se sont révélés
inefficaces à la fois sur les
recrutements et sur les salaires donc
encore une fois on partage tous le même
objectif moi vous le savez j'ai pas de
tabou sur les allègements de cotisation
les baisses de cotisation je pense que
quand c'est
ça vous le savez non mais vous le savez
donc ça donc ça rend donc ça rend ma
position ça rend ma position d'autant
plus forte et objective moi je pense que
oui oui il y a des exonérations et des
allègements qui sont utiles mais il faut
qu'on soit sûr de leur efficacité en
l'occurrence là je crains un effet
d'aubaine qui met notre branche famille
dans le rouge donc pour ces raisons
défavorables
merci alors nous allons commencer
mille excuses de rallonger un peu le
débat mais je préfère répondre je répète
je préfère répondre tout de suite à
monsieur le ministre c'est le ministre
je ne crois pas que vous n'avez pas
compris le dispositif je pense que vous
avez la posture du gardien du temple ce
que je comprends bien du temple
financier je le comprends bien non non
il est pas question que les CDI de 60
ans soit tous pris en compte dans ce
dispositif il est question de proposer
une alternative d'où l'intérêt des
branches de définir dans les branches
l'intérêt de ce CDI non jusqu'à présent
dans les CDI on discute pas d'histoire
d'âge avec avec le salarié tandis que là
ça veut dire que il y a un aspect très
confidentiel jusqu'à présent où le
salarié expose ses conditions de
retraite on regarde sur un faux retraite
les conditions c'est comme un contrat de
chantier donc ça veut dire que par
rapport à ces exonérations de tous les
emplois de 60 ans vous auriez vous
auriez
une embauche supplémentaire de seniors
c'est la raison pour laquelle ça mérite
d'exister alors maintenant vous parlez
d'histoire de bornage pas de bornage moi
je suis mais alors à 100% d'accord avec
vous mais 100% mais pourquoi pourquoi
dans l'article suivant vous nous
proposez des bornages pour les carrières
longues parce qu'effectivement celui qui
a 4 à Sainte trimestre avant la fin de
l'année de l'âge d'un tel mais pas de
peau à chaque fois qu'on a eu des
discussions avec nos collègues ils m'ont
demandé tiens je suis questionné Ah bah
non il a que trois trimestres celui-là
il en a pas 4 à 5 les bordages c'est
terrible c'est la raison pour laquelle
moi on en est mieux c'est mais si on met
pas des bandages dans votre dispositif
monsieur le ministre vous me parlez des
bandes pour le calcul des cotisations
soit les bornes c'est bien soit les
bornes c'est pas bien vous avez mis des
bornes de cotisations différentes
4,5,15 au sud de 3,5 SMIC et puis en
dessous un taux différentiel j'en sais
rien mais des bornes effectivement ça
devient incontournable quoi hein donc
soyons attentifs la CSG c'est déborde et
là ça veut dire effectivement vous me
coûtez trop cher donc finalement je vais
vous payer moins cher comme ça j'ai une
cotisation qui est en dessous donc on
voit bien que tout ça faut voir le
dispositif alors soyez une volonté
d'accepter le dispositif soit il y a
effectivement il y a la volonté de pas
l'accepter et mes chers collègues je
vous incite plutôt à aller dans le sens
de la Commission de façon à donner
davantage d'espoir au seigneur merci
nous allons donc
voter d'abord les sous amendements pour
le beau dort oui oui non non vous pouvez
expliquer votre vote et aucun problème
et je vais et je signale que je suis
saisi du demande de scrutin public sur
l'amendement de la commission présentée
par les rapporteurs le 21/12 qui aura
lieu à la fin de l'examen des
sous-amendements pour le bon ordre de
nos débats
alors madame lui va
merci monsieur le président
moi je ne comprends pas pourquoi on est
toujours obligé de faire des cadeaux aux
entreprises pour que elle recrute des
gens soit c'est des jeunes soit c'est
des seniors soit c'est finalement et
alors les entreprises recrutent qui des
gens qui ont entre 25 et 55 ans et puis
après avant ça va pas après ça va plus
moi j'aurais préféré que l'on me demande
de juste aux entreprises en fonction de
certains critères de recruter ou de
maintenir un emploi des seniors pour
qu'elle puisse garder les diverses
exonérations auxquelles elles ont déjà
droit
on n'aurait pas eu besoin d'en rajouter
on leur demanderait un effort par
rapport à ce à quoi elles ont déjà droit
nous nous avons fait aussi par exemple
une proposition
de d'un recrutement ou enfin ou plutôt
de la présence d'un minimum de 15 % ou
d'un plancher de 15 % de seniors dans
les entreprises
en gérant le flux c'est à dire soit on
ne se débarrasse pas des gens de plus de
55 ans et lorsqu'on a des postes à
pourvoir on ne on ne comment dire on ne
se prive pas des candidatures de gens de
plus de 55 ans ça aurait déjà été un bon
me semble-t-il une bonne proposition
puis la dernière des remarques elle est
générale elle est d'ordre général le
Medef qui a été auditionné et que nous
avions vu aussi l'occasion d'auditionner
avec René Paul Savary le Medef est
particulièrement favorable à ce projet
de report de l'âge de recul de l'âge de
la retraite et dans le même temps
il y est favorable mais il refuse
catégoriquement de faire des efforts en
matière de recrutement des gens de plus
de 50 ans voilà donc j'ai envie de dire
ça devient un petit peu pénible quand
même et à un moment il faudra bien
trouver un moyen et moi je le propose
c'est au travers des exonérations déjà
existantes et je vais terminer en disant
que j'ai lu dans la presse ce matin que
le gouvernement je vous donne de la TVA
là
ah pardon j'ai lu dans la presse ce
matin que le gouvernement avait un
nouveau concept on allait nous servir un
nouveau concept pensez printemps il va
se passer plein de choses au printemps
moi j'aurais aimé qu'on pense automne
c'est à dire qu'on nous propose une loi
travail avant une loi retraite monsieur
chanterelle et chacun respecte bien son
temps
merci monsieur le Président alors
monsieur le rapporteur Sabari vous aurez
dû renommer votre amendement
l'amendement Medef parce que c'est c'est
une commande directe du Medef cette
mesure va dans le bon sens à déclarer
Eric chevet le vice-président de la CPME
on n'est pas étonné de sa réaction parce
que avec ce CDI senior vous allez
permettre au patron d'être exonéré des
cotisations familles c'est à dire 5% du
salaire brut tout de même au passage le
ministre des comptes publics monsieur
Attal qui lui n'est pas là pour faire
une réforme de gauche mais pour serrer
la vis vous êtes à l'armée justement du
coup pour les finances publiques 800
millions d'euros
on se demande bien ce qui va rester des
économies prévues soit disant par la
réforme avec le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite mais veut revenons à la
proposition du rapporteur pourquoi donc
des honorations de cotisation famille
quel rapport avec l'emploi des sonneurs
aucun si ce n'est d'en profiter pour
siphonner la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale redevenu excédentaire
en 2021 non en fait c'est parce que
Monsieur Savary n'a pas eu le choix de
son propre aveu dans une entrevue que
vous avez donné à Ouest-France vous avez
dit il aurait été plus judicieux de
proposer une exonération de cotisations
chômage et oui mais la réforme des
retraites passe par un projet de loi
rectificatif de financement de la
sécurité sociale et l'assurance chômage
est en dehors de ce cadre voilà sur la
forme le résumé de toute l'absurdité du
débat que nous sommes en train d'avoir
mais sur le fond avec ce CDI dérégulé et
à bas coût que va-t-il se passer on
risque de mettre en concurrence avec les
jeunes sur le seul critère du coup du
travail or les jeunes eux-mêmes ont
aussi beaucoup de mal à s'insérer c'est
la raison pour laquelle monsieur sabery
nous vous trouvons contre votre maman je
suis gay
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues moi je
voudrais d'abord remercier le rapporteur
Savary parce qu'avec cet amendement il
me rappelle ma jeunesse où je me suis
engagé en 2006 contre le contrat
première embauche et nous avions obtenu
le retrait comme nous obtiendrons le
retrait je le sais de cette réforme des
retraites et je trouve l'expression de
nos collègues Lubin très fort à propos
le contrat dernier embauche bon
premièrement
on a d'abord les effets
quand on a reporté l'âge légal de 60 à
62 ans ça a été nul sur l'embauche des
seniors qui n'était pas au travail nul
et donc les 1 million 4 de personnes qui
sont entre 53 et 69 ans qui sont
aujourd'hui sans emploi ni revenus il y
aura pas plus d'embauche avec ce contrat
dernier embauche premièrement la
deuxième l'argument de du ministrateur
est fort à propos là aussi c'est qu'on
va signer la branche famille des
cotisations sociales et on va la sécher
donc je n'y reviens pas c'est mieux
quand c'est lui qui le dit plutôt que le
groupe communiste dernière chose
les exonérations de cotisations là on va
avoir un point divergent avec évidemment
monsieur le ministre
on a déjà quand même un certain nombre
de choses pour les évaluer par exemple
cice qui s'est transformé en exonération
de cotisation je lis le rapport France
stratégie le dernier date 2020 les
résultats restent conformes aux
conclusions des années précédentes un
fort effet emploi est trouvé chez le
quart des entreprises les plus
bénéficiaires du cice qui ne
représentent qu'un huitième des
effectifs mais rien ne significatif chez
les autres l'effet total restait si mais
à 5000 emplois nous en avaient promis un
million à l'époque ce qui est faible
rapporté au coût du cice de l'ordre de
18 milliards 18 milliards pour 5000
emplois ça fait 180000 euros pour chaque
emploi qu'on sait que ça a l'air médian
est aux alentours de 33000 euros chargé
donc vous voyez ça ne marchera toujours
pas je vous remercie monsieur le
Président Madame Brulin
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres mes chers collègues c'est vrai
que ce contrat en envie de l'appeler
dernière embauche pour les raisons que
viennent de rappeler Monique Lubin et
Fabien gay
mais je suis pas davantage d'accord avec
le fait qu'on en dise que c'est un CDI
parce que un contrat dont on connaît
l'âge de début et l'âge de fin ça
ressemble quand même beaucoup plus à un
CDD qui a un CDI
enfin les exonérations effectivement
sur la branche femme vous nous avez
expliqué monsieur le rapporteur que
votre préférence aurait été à des
exonérations de cotisations chômage tout
ça confirme qu'on est quand même de plus
en plus dans du bricolage autour de
cette réforme et c'est ça n'est pas sans
nous inquiéter et puis ça donne quand
même l'impression que certains ici ne
supportent pas qu'une branche de notre
système de protection sociale soit
excédentaire la branche famille enfin
mes chers collègues on va entendre un
peu différemment tout ce que vous allez
nous dire prochainement sur ce que vous
voulez faire en direction des familles
quand dès que vous en avez l'occasion
vous diminuez les recettes pour la
branche famille on pourrait dire la même
chose de la branche accident du travail
maladie professionnelle qui elle aussi
est devenue excédentaire et qui à la
faveur de cette réforme va se voir aussi
spolier un certain nombre de ressources
on a bien compris monsieur le ministre
que les exonérations de cotisation
n'étaient pas tabou pour vous c'est même
malheureusement quasiment la seule
solution que vous mettez en avant à
quasiment chaque problème or il y a des
exonérations de cotisation qui se sont
multipliées pour les basses à l'air ce
qui a contribué à tirer les salaires
vers le bas qui des salaires qui sont
plutôt d'ailleurs le fait de début de
carrière et aujourd'hui on en prend
argument pour dire bah il faudrait aussi
des exonérations de cotisations pour les
fins de carrière parce que sinon ils
sont plus concurrentiels avec les débuts
de carrière et puis ensuite on va nous
dire bah écoutez pour tous les autres il
va falloir aussi des exonérations et
c'est comme ça qu'on arrive à la
situation que connaît notre financement
de la protection sociale nous proposons
de prendre le chemin exactement inverse
madame Bocquet
monsieur Bocquet c'est Madame briquet
auquel je pensais non non j'ai aucun
doute on va bien monsieur le Président
les semaines se suivent et de se
ressemblent pas la semaine dernière nous
combintions pieds à pied une aspiration
une réforme d'aspiration libérale votre
choix est depuis hier le monde a changé
nous grâce à la presse nous apprenons
que nous contestons désormais une
réforme de gauche ce matin
je voulais partager avec vous ce
sentiment mes chers collègues sentiment
très étrange pour le groupe communiste
en attendant ce contrat de fin de
carrière censé favoriser l'embauche des
seniors s'appuie sur un seul argument
d'attractivité cela a été dit par mes
collègues l'exonération des cotisations
familiales de l'employeur exonération
que nous combattons parce que elles ont
le fâcheuse inconvénient de créer du
déficit de d'affaiblir les recettes d'un
régime et donc nous combattons pieds à
pied cette logique là alors pensons
sérieusement améliorer le taux d'emploi
des seniors qui est je le rappelle de
56% pour les 55 64 ans en exonérant les
employeurs d'une cotisation actuellement
fixée à
3,45%, soit une économie de 129 euros
sur un salarié payé à 3745 euros vous
pensez résoudre la question des seniors
licenciés à 59 ans en baissant de 60
euros les cotisations des entreprises
sur un salaire médian qui franchement
croira à cette fable
monsieur le Président rénal
oui merci monsieur le Président bien
comment dire j'ai le plaisir ce matin
d'être d'accord pour la première fois
avec des deux ministres présents et
j'allais dire sur l'ensemble des
arguments me semble-t-il bon
et voyez-vous je crois monsieur le
rapporteur je vous crois de bonne foi je
le dis dans votre recherche d'une
solution mais ensuite la bonne foi
n'excuse pas le fait qu'il faut entendre
des choses qui sont vraies et qui sont
me semble-t-il tout à fait justifiés
l'effet d'aubaine
bon ben ça ça existe toujours il y a
même un effet domaine qui pourrait être
encore plus plus terrible ça serait de
licencier un an avant et ensuite de
réembaucher selon un nouveau contrat pas
les mêmes personnes mais d'autres
personnes donc si vous voulez on connaît
les pratiques de certaines entreprises
c'est pas tous les chefs d'entreprise
heureusement mais de certains
entreprises qui jouent effectivement sur
les effets d'aubaine et nous les
connaissons
l'exonération famille j'y reviens pas
c'est curieux de proposer l'exonérations
familles mais vous l'avez expliqué
c'était pas votre objectif mais voilà et
puis leur envoi à la négociation
interprofessionnelle c'est du bon sens
c'est du bon sens vous l'avez dit
d'ailleurs vous-même il faut y revenir
mais laissons levenir laissons le venir
de la négociation interprofessionnelle
les sons chercher les solutions au
niveau au niveau des branches je pense
que c'est comme ça bon donc pour moi le
sujet numéro un d'ailleurs c'est pas
celui-là c'est d'abord de conserver les
seniors qui sont au travail avant de
savoir comment on réembauche comment
dans les entreprises on maintient les
gens au travail jusqu'à à l'âge à la fin
de l'âge légal au minimum
donc moi je vous demanderai au vu de ce
qui s'est dit et de ce qui s'est dit de
manière à tout à fait correcte
je vous remercierai monsieur le
rapporteur de considérer que vous avez
fait
œuvre utile que vous avez déposé un
amant de la bande d'appel et que
maintenant au vu de ce qui s'est dit
très logiquement vous le retirez madame
pour ce poli
si monsieur le Président alors nous nous
opposons évidemment fermement à cet
amendement des rapporteurs nous avons
déjà bien du mal à trouver je vous le
rappelle de l'emploi et un CDI pour les
jeunes et vous n'avez vous pour ligne de
mire que de tirer sur une rognambulance
à savoir évidemment exploiter jusqu'à la
dernière force des seigneurs et puis
vous avez certainement reçu évidemment
les félicitations du Medef pour votre
belle amendement parce qu'il le réclame
à corps et à crise vous nous assumez de
cette réforme est une réforme de justice
sociale pourtant il s'agit bien notre
cassé encore plus nos seigneurs avant
même de vous parler du droit au repos ou
comme vous aimez l'appeler ici dans
cette hémicycle le droit à la paresse
nous vous rappelons que le droit
fondamental au respect de la vie privée
familiale que vous torpillez que cela
soit avec la réforme mais également avec
cet amendement déconnecter complètement
déconnecté de la réalité du travail de
la durée de la dure réalité du labeur
des salariés de ce pays pour bien
détrailleurs à chaque jour suffit sa
peine et par cet amendement vous
souhaitez nous vendre comme de mauvais
publicitaires que vous êtes l'idée selon
laquelle nos seniors n'attendent qu'une
seule chose continuer continuer à
travailler mes chers collègues cet
amendement ne parle à personne si ce
n'est qu'au patron vous vous détachez de
la réalité de millions de Français de
celle de millions de travailleurs
précaires pour favoriser une foi encore
les mêmes et vous envisagez de les
choyer de surcroît en les exonération de
cotisations sociales ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il est absolument contre-productif de
recruter des personnes qui sont usées à
des postes qui nécessitent motivation et
à endurance votre amendement contrevient
à toute forme de pertinence et
d'humanité
nous votre rond contre merci Monsieur
Chaumier
merci Monsieur président écoutez ce
dispositif au moins un mérite c'est
comme il comporte une disposition sur
les cotisations sociales et les
conformes à une LSS ce qui est pas le
cas de tous les articles donc il faut
quand même le noter pour le reste le
rapporteur a fait un lien intéressant
d'ailleurs à souvenir entre la
production et les exonérations de
cotisations moi je veux dire j'ai
regardé les résultats ils sont pas
flagrants franchement depuis que cette
politique est devenue massive notamment
depuis 2018
on peut pas dire que la balance
commerciale de la France se soit
vraiment amélioré c'est fortement
dégradé et nos capacités de production
sont pas fortement en hausse c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire c'est un
euphémisme donc la question qui se pose
c'est que ces exonérations de
cotisations surtout elles sont un
phénomène permanent de modification de
la dépense publique dans notre pays
c'est là où ce projet de loi retraite a
aussi un versant qui est intéressant on
transfère toujours plus
d'argent vers les entreprises la dépense
publique c'est une baisse des dépenses
en faveur des services publics et les
gens ils le voient partout autour d'eux
c'est pas la peine de répéter la justice
où elle en est la santé etc
c'est des dépenses vers les ménages et
là on y est au cœur avec la question des
retraites et c'est du transfert vers les
entreprises et quand on passe de 2018 à
2023 de 38 à 73 milliards d'euros les
exonérations de cotisations sociales et
qu'on augmente massivement les transfert
vers les entreprises il faut bien
prendre l'argent quelque part alors on
le prend sur les services publics qui
sont à l'os et quand même partout dans
nos départements c'est la catastrophe et
on le prend maintenant sur le transfert
vers les ménages là en voulant récupérer
de l'argent sur le système de retraite
alors tout ça est un choix politique
très clair mais il faut l'assumer
maintenant il faut l'assumer et je suis
heureux qu'une part oui oui dans votre
camp chez les républicains il y a des
députés qui ouvrent les yeux et qui
disent ça suffit on ne peut plus aller
dans ce sens là Monsieur Hainaut
oui merci monsieur le Président c'est le
Ministre d'abord une remarque monsieur
chanterelle a dit tout à l'heure que
monsieur le rapporteur répondait à une
commande du Medef je trouve cette
remarque désobligeante déplacée et ça
vous grandit pas voilà et comme vous
êtes coutumier du fait je voulais le
faire ce matin je vous remercie
[Applaudissements]
bien sûr sur cette question sur cette
amendement nous avons un doute sur le
risque d'effets d'aubaines
nous avons naturellement ce doute moi
j'avoue que s'il y avait pas eu
l'article 40 d'ailleurs sans doute que
j'aurais déposé un amendement plutôt sur
une prime que sur une exonération ceci
dit j'ai été sensible aux arguments du
du rapporteur sur les partenaires
sociaux et la négociation raison pour
laquelle je retire mes deux sous
amendements et je pense que on fait un
pari parce que si on si on augmente pas
la quantité de travail et la quantité
des seniors au travail bien évidemment
alors je suis sensible à l'argument de
Madame Rossignol et au risque
d'affaiblir le financement de la branche
famille mais on fait un pari et ce Paris
nous devons le faire d'augmenter le taux
de travail de des seniors pour financer
notre système de retraite par
répartition je pense d'ailleurs et c'est
la raison pour laquelle je retire ces
deux sous amendements
ils nous devons chaque fois que nous le
pouvons laisser le plus de l'attitude
possible à la négociation des
partenaires sociaux c'est l'état
d'esprit qui est celui de notre groupe
si nous voulons aussi redonner du grain
à moudre et faire en sorte qu'on ait un
pari tarisme refondé et rénové et ce
sera une dépression de de la loi travail
à venir je vous remercie merci Monsieur
Breuillet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur du
ministre chers collègues j'ai commencé
par un point d'accord avec ce que vient
de dire monsieur Hainaut je pense
qu'effectivement il s'agit d'un chantier
qui devrait être ouvert avec les
partenaires sociaux dans la négociation
interprofessionnelle avant de venir en
débat parmi nous bien sûr il y a un
énorme problème du travail des seniors
nous l'avons d'ailleurs évoqué
longuement hier à propos de l'index pour
lequel il y a un refus de toute mesure
contraignante
ce chantier devrait donc être ouvert
avec les partenaires sociaux et je veux
dire un point d'accord avec le ministre
Attal aussi sur les critiques qu'il fait
du dispositif un point d'accord
notamment lorsqu'il critique les mesures
de bornes
mais j'ai espéré qu'il y avait pas de à
c'était pas les mesures de bornes alors
c'est moi qui est qui est
j'avais mal compris monsieur le ministre
j'ai pensé qu'il pouvait y avoir un
sous-entendu donc c'était juste les
mesures d'âge pardon mais effectivement
il peut y avoir un effet de bornes ou de
seuil avec une mesure comme celle-là et
notamment qui impacterait des gens âgés
de 58 59 ans dans la question de l'accès
à l'emploi et tout aussi importantes et
puis enfin dernière remarque on parle
toujours d'exonération et ensuite on
parle toujours des déficits de
l'ensemble des caisses publiques donc
comme l'a évoqué un collègue et je
m'excuse de ne pas le citer avant moi je
suggère effectivement qu'on diminue pour
inciter les entreprises embauchées
peut-être dans le cadre de l'index qu'on
diminue les très nombreuses exonérations
qui leur sont accordés à celles qui ne
respectent pas le taux d'emploi des
seniors ou et qui maintiennent à celles
qui embauche en tous les cas qu'on
souligne l'intérêt de maintenir ces
exonérations uniquement pour ceux qui
embauchent réellement ou qui servent les
enjeux climatiques
monsieur le Président Retailleau
moi je considère que
l'amendement de René Paul Savary que
nous allons voter évidemment
révèle un enjeu qui est un des plus
grand de cette réforme parce que à quoi
servirait-il d'augmenter de reculer
l'âge légal de départ si on ne fait rien
sur l'emploi des seniors vous savez
parfaitement que le taux de chômage et
un certain nombre de sénatrices et de
sénateurs de l'opposition l'ont répété
hier touche tout particulièrement les
seniors et nous nous contentons pas de
ce que nous dit le gouvernement le
gouvernement dit mais nous on a un outil
extraordinaire
c'est l'index l'index est une
statistique certes il y aura l'effet
diamondshine en bon vendéen pardon mais
ça n'est pas suffisant nous voulons
trouver un autre outil et c'est ce qu'a
fait la commission la commission nous a
dit on peut peut-être trouver à travers
ce nouveau contrat qui va s'adresser à
des seniors un outil qui permettra de
lutter contre le chômage des seniors
vous faites plusieurs reproches je
veiller répondre René Paul Savary a
répondu au reproches de la négociation
avec les partenaires sociaux il y a
trois reproches essentiellement vous ne
dites un effet d'Aubagne oui il y aurait
eu un effet d'aubaine si le contrat
s'adressait au plus de 60 ans qui sont
déjà dans l'entreprise non là ça ne sera
pas le cas ce sera des gens qu'on va
sortir du chômage et qui vont rentrer
sur le marché du travail première chose
et vous savez parfaitement parfaitement
qu'on embauche très très peu en France
après 60 ans donc il y a pas d'effet
d'Aubagne il y a pas d'effet double
deuxième reproche que vous faites sur le
coup nous contestons formellement nous
contestons formellement le coût du
gouvernement nous le contestons parce
que le gouvernement
ne regarde qu'une ligne la ligne de la
dépense mais il s'agit d'activer en
réalité des dépenses chômage
d'indemnisation et il s'agit de faire en
sorte que des gens qui bénéficient
bénéficier parce qu'ils ont un emploi
des économies sont chiffrées ce à quoi
revient par exemple 100 000 seniors
qu'on réintègre sur le marché du travail
c'est près d'un milliard donc vous voyez
que c'est une mesure qui à notre sens ne
coûtera pas mais au contraire rapportera
et troisième élément troisième reproche
que vous avez fait ça va assécher la
branche famille non puisque pour
l'instant ils sont au chômage il n'y a
pas de cotisations famille donc il
s'agit encore une fois et c'est l'esprit
d'ailleurs de la réforme de réactiver et
de faire en sorte le dos d'activité
grandissent dans l'économie pardon
monsieur le président
madame le héros
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président excusez-moi
vous proposez d'instaurer un nouveau
type de contrat de travail afin de
favoriser l'emploi d'un seigneur mais la
question n'est pas de créer un nouveau
CDI mais que les entreprises gardent
leur salarié de 55 ans et plus votre
proposition risque de mettre en
concurrence des seniors avec les jeunes
sur le seul critère du coût du travail
sachant que les jeunes aussi ont du mal
à s'insérer vous exonérer les
entreprises de cotisation familiales
donc vous ponctionnez ça vient d'être
dit les caisses d'allocations familiales
la protection sociale de nos familles or
nous savons que cette politique
familiale a besoin de moyens pour mettre
en place un vrai service public de la
petite enfance il nous manque des places
en crèche nous avons besoin de moyens
pour financer les congés pour l'égalité
femme homme soit une soit en réalité
tout simplement le l'égalité
professionnelle qui passe aussi par une
égalité des droits des deux parents à
accompagner l'arrivée de l'enfant dans
le foyer
nous avons besoin de cotisations pour
compenser les congés de maternité alors
que les femmes pour que les femmes et
les mêmes droits au départ à la retraite
d'ailleurs monsieur le ministre du socle
avec le la première ministre vous
considériez initialement que les
exonérations de cotisation n'était pas
le meilleur moyen pour agir sur l'emploi
des seniors alors quels sont les
éléments qui vous ont fait changer
d'avis il serait intéressant pour nous
de les connaître pour notre part nous ne
changions pas d'avis le meilleur moyen
de maintenir les seigneurs en emploi
jusque 62 ans et de ne pas changer l'âge
légal de départ nous savons déjà que un
salarié sur deux n'est pas en emploi sur
la tranche d'âge des 50-64 ans de 55 64
ans merci Madame Ferré
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voulais
revenir sur la question du véhicule
législatif vous allez me dire encore et
toujours oui encore et toujours parce
que à nouveau avec cette article
additionnel et bien on voit que le
véhicule législatif que le gouvernement
a choisi n'est pas le bon vous avez dit
je vais revenir sur les propos de
Monsieur le rapporteur il aurait été
plus judicieux de proposer une
exonération de cotisation chômage dans
la mesure où l'embauche de seigneur
réduit le chômage oui mais problème nous
sommes dans une loi de finances
rectificative et l'assurance chômage
étant dehors de ce cadre alors oui ce
véhicule législatif n'est décidément pas
le bon s'agissant des exonérations et la
proposition qui est faite d'exonérer au
travers de ce CDI comme ma collègue je
m'interroge CDI c'est qu'on n'est pas de
fin quand on ne connaît pas la fin là on
la connaît cette date de fin puisque
c'est la date de départ en retraite de
la personne qui serait recruter donc
plutôt de ce CDD monsieur le ministre
vous vous je vous dis les exonérations
de cotisations ne sont pas le meilleur
moyen pour développer l'emploi des
seigneurs des seniors pour moi pardon
pour moi ce n'est pas le meilleur moyen
c'est ça n'est pas le moyen pour
développer l'emploi des seniors c'est
effectivement monsieur atteint le
ministre que vous avez dit que le coût
de cet amendement serait de 800 millions
d'euros c'est pas rien c'est pas rien
tout comme si on additionne et si on
regarde l'ensemble du coup ou l'ensemble
des exonérations employeurs qui sont de
l'ordre de 80 milliards d'euros alors
cessons de faire des propositions qui
pourraient convenir plutôt et je le dis
moi aussi
sans complexe et en assumant
complètement ce que je dis qui sont de
véritables cadeaux aux entreprises ce
sont d'être dans cette volonté d'aider
les entreprises et non pas celles et
ceux qui sont sans emploi parce que
aussi le risque est réel de mettre en
concurrence les seniors et les jeunes
avec ce les critères du coût du travail
madame la Présidente Laurence Rossignol
je n'imagine pas que cet amendement puis
se être amendement d'appel
Marc d'abord au ministre qui nous dit
j'ai pas de tabou sur les exonérations
sociales
oui un peu quand même vous en avez
monsieur le ministre parce que 75
milliards annuels d'exonération de
charges sociales et un discours
permanent sur les déficits publics mais
jamais aucun lien n'est fait entre le
montant le volume des exonérations de
charge sociale et le montant des
déficits publics pour autant il y en a
un et celui-là il est toujours dans le
tabou puisque vous n'en parlez pas
deuxième remarque c'est que vous
monsieur Savary et je pense que vous
êtes sincère quand vous le dites vous
renvoyez à la négocié à la consultation
des partenaires sociaux permettant de
vous dire que en ce moment sur la
consultation des partenaires sociaux à
l'initiative de ce gouvernement on est
pour le moins prudent sur la nature de
cette concertation et ce que les
partenaires sociaux pourraient obtenir
comme garantie dans une négociation avec
le gouvernement qui a décidé de ne plus
de s'émanciper de la vie des partenaires
sociaux en matière de politique social
parce que dans cet amendement moi j'ai
pas tout compris mais peut-être que
peut-être j'ai pas été assez comment
dire rigoureuse ou attentive vous avez
dit tout à l'heure que l'employeur
s'engage à garder le salarié nonobstant
l'ensemble de toutes les autres règles
du Code du travail concernant le
licenciement par exemple je n'imagine
pas qu'il s'agisse d'un engagement qui
émancie qui protège le travailleur dans
toutes les circonstances donc comment ça
s'articuler avec le licenciement
habituel pour faute pour le sentiment
économique plan social à ce moment-là il
y a plus d'engagement donc là on a
besoin quand même je crois de
retravailler un peu et puis tout à
l'heure le président Retailleau nous a
dit que à la fois que il voyait pas bien
enfin qu'il y avait un lien entre cet
amendement et le recul d'âge et puis
notre collègue Olivier Hainaut a dit que
c'était un pari alors moi j'aime bien
que les paris soit équitables il y a ça
c'est un pari mais le recul d'âge dans
l'esprit du gouvernement c'est pas un
pari c'est un coup près qui va qui va
qui s'appliquerait dès le vote de la loi
merci Monsieur Fichet
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Ministre c'est juste une précision
parce que Corinne Ferrer en a fait état
tout à l'heure on parle de CDI mais en
fait c'est un CDD dont il s'agit à CDD
de 4 ans puisqu'il sera signé à l'âge de
60 ans et à 64 ans c'est terminé il y a
donc une sorte de CDD vieux ou de
contrats de dernière embauche en fait en
plus on ne peut pas comprendre le fait
que ça s'arrête à 64 ans puisque si les
personnes souhaitent aller jusqu'à 70
ans ce n'est que mieux puisque c'est
même personne pendant ce temps-là
démarreront pas aux caisses de retraite
donc autant d'économie de fait je crois
que du coup ça vaut le coup d'y
réfléchir je vous remercie et Madame
meunier
c'est le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues tout d'abord
moi je voudrais dire que je me réjouis
de la tonalité de nos propos et de la
belle qualité des débats ce matin ça
augure je pense d'une belle semaine à
venir
monsieur Savary le rapporteur ça varie
vous avez dit vous-même que par cet
amendement qui n'est qu'un outil nouveau
c'est un site que vous l'avez qualifié
certes mais c'est un outil au service
d'une mécanique que nous ne voulons pas
donc désolé mais ne je ne voterai pas
votre amendement monsieur le ministre
Attal vous avez dit que c'était un
risque mais c'est l'ensemble du projet
de loi qui est un risque un risque pour
les personnes qui sont concernées les
plus modestes celles qui ont travaillé
dans des métiers les plus difficiles et
qui verront de fait deux ans
supplémentaires de cotisations avant de
partir à la retraite et puis vous dites
que vous n'avez pas de tabous ça a été
souligné tout à l'heure des tabous
concernant les exonérations et ça je
veux bien vous croire par contre vous
avez des tabous concernant les recettes
et les possibilités de recettes
nouvelles nous vous en avons fait de ce
côté de l'hémicycle et vous persistez à
ne pas les entendre la taxation sur les
supers profits les contributions sur les
eaux salaires et les grosses fortunes et
toutes celles que nous avons pu aussi
décliner que déclinerons tout au long de
ce débat merci merci
merci monsieur le Président
moi je rejoins tout à fait ce que disait
tout à l'heure le Président retaillod si
on ne fait rien pour inciter à
l'embauche des seniors on passe à côté
d'un point essentiel c'est très fort
j'ai auditionné avec le groupe le
professeur Lorenzi président du Cercle
des économistes qui a calculé que si en
France nous rattrapions tout simplement
le déficit dans l'emploi des seniors
rappelle que ces 10 points de déficit
par rapport à la moyenne de l'OCDE ça
rapporterait 13 milliards pour notre
système de retraite 13 milliards
je crois que les chiffres parlent
d'eux-mêmes
d'ailleurs je crois que sur le ministre
dans vos
papiers notamment ceux qui nous ont été
donnés lorsque nous avions fait le bilan
d'étape vous parliez de pour cent mille
emplois créés de seniors un milliard de
recettes supplémentaires vous pouvez le
confirmer j'ai imagine aisément je les
élus ce sont des chiffres qui nous
permettent d'envisager et je rejoins
tout à fait la position que
défendait tout à l'heure Olivier et nous
plutôt une prime à l'embauche que des
exonérations
les exonérations on le sait tous les
PLFSS on se plaint des exonérations et
l'État est obligé de compenser les
exonérations depuis le vote de la loi
organique n'est-ce pas monsieur le
ministre donc je crois que le plus
simple ce serait de mettre une prime à
l'embauche
quant à un emploi rapporte enfin 100000
emplois rapportent un milliard on sait
qu'on peut libérer effectivement
quelques centaines de millions pour
pouvoir permettre à des seniors de
retrouver effectivement la dignité du
travail merci
[Applaudissements]
et ensuite ce sera le président Gontard
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres je crois que à travers les
discussions que nous avons nous
constatons très bien qu'il ne s'agit pas
d'une proposition de loi de gauche plus
on avance plus on se rend compte que
cette proposition est que les
différentes propositions qui sont faits
également notamment celles qui a été
faite par notre rapporteur et bien ne
correspondent pas il faudrait une vraie
loi pour parler de la retraite pour
parler du travail des jeunes des jeunes
et pour parler des seniors parce que là
on est dans la confusion on est dans le
bricolage et ce n'est pas le bon
véhicule pour aller en Guadeloupe je
prends l'avion je ne vais pas prendre
une trottinette donc bien on est dans un
cas de figure qui serait similaire donc
je crois aujourd'hui que nous devons
être sérieux nous devons travailler dans
l'intérêt premier des seniors et là la
façon d'aborder les choses dans
l'appréhender s'apparente à une façon de
les maltraités les la météo pour fille
des entreprises parce que les éléments
qui sont évoqués chacun entendu mais
c'est pas normal ce n'est pas normal
parler de la broche family moi je veux
bien parce qu'il y a beaucoup à faire et
ma collègue vient de discuter de
proposer un certain nombre de pistes
nous ne pouvons pas faire n'importe quoi
nous ne devons pas faire n'importe quoi
dans mon territoire la question des
jeunes se pose beaucoup plus que des
seigneurs mais les seigneurs aussi donc
nous devons mettre en oeuvre tout ce
qu'il faut tous les moyens pour une
vraie loi de retraite et ne pas faire
n'importe quoi pour les seniors les
maltraités c'est maltraités les enfants
c'est maltraiter les plus jeunes c'est
maltraiter la société merci
président comptable
monsieur kerouche se prépare
très rapidement je voulais juste lever
peut-être une petite incohérence parce
que j'ai écouté le président Retailleau
tout à l'heure et
puis j'ai regardé ce qu'il avait pu dire
et dans une belle envolée je crois que
c'était hier sur les bienfaits du recul
de l'âge et il nous disait le recul de
l'âge procure un autre avantage nous
allons automatiquement mécaniquement
augmenter le temps d'emploi des seniors
et ainsi mettre plus de travail dans la
machine et donc je m'étonne un petit peu
que du coup aujourd'hui on nous explique
bah que non justement mécaniquement
automatiquement ça ne fonctionnera pas
mais qu'il faut un dispositif un autre
dispositif peut-être de l'huile du coup
dans la machine pour pouvoir employer
ces seniors donc c'est vrai que là je
vois une petite une petite incohérence
que j'aimerais bien lever parce que ça
me paraît important d'ailleurs tarlin un
de vos collègues nous ont dit si on ne
fait rien on aura on aura tout faux donc
voilà j'aimerais j'aimerais essayer de
de comprendre parce que c'est vrai que
si justement ce bien fait de l'âge de
recul à la retraite ces fameux deux ans
vont nous permettre mécaniquement il me
semble que ce dispositif pour le coup ne
sert à rien à moins que ça soit
simplement un faux CDI et simplement une
voix de garage
merci monsieur le Président sur le
dispositif qui nous est proposé on ne
peut que contester son existence parce
que le problème c'est sa finalité qu'on
a du mal à percevoir c'est quoi la vraie
la vraie finalité de ce contrat qui est
un contrat dont on imagine mal
l'apporter dans le temps avec toutes les
limites qui ont été qui ont été imposées
et puis on a entendu monsieur le
ministre monsieur Attal nous dire que
cette
disposition aurait un effet particulier
puisqu'elle coûte elle coûterait 800 800
millions d'euros mais je suis un peu
surpris par la dualité du discours parce
que quand il s'agit de supprimer la taxe
d'habitation à peu près 26 milliards
d'euros dont 8 milliards pour les 20%
les les plus les plus aisés quand on
supprime la CVAE là
l'exécutif fait des paris et on n'a pas
du tout de vision sur ce qui vont être
ou ce qui pourrait être les conséquences
c'est des paris par contre quand il est
question d'augmenter même de manière
modérée les recettes sociales pour
financer la protection sociale là ce
n'est plus possible d'en parler il y a
tout un ensemble de solutions qui
existent et que nous vous proposons
régulièrement comme l'augmentation du
taux d'emploi des seniors comme
l'égalité homme-femme comme simplement
comme l'a montré Thomas Piketty
l'augmentation de 2% de la CSG sur les
hauts patrimoine qui viendrait compenser
l'ensemble des besoins du système de
retraite la vraie question c'est
pourquoi d'un côté vous êtes
relativement timoré et pourquoi de
l'autre il faudrait alors vous faire
confiance à vos gel
oui merci monsieur le Président je
voulais aller dans le sens du de mon
collègue Guillaume Gontard pour dire que
nous trouvons ici dans une situation un
peu un peu curieuse on a d'un côté dans
ce côté-là de l'hémicycle des collègues
qui nous disent cette réforme est
nécessaire et elle est très utile
notamment pour l'emploi des seniors
parce automatiquement en augmentant
l'âge légal de départ à la retraite on
va augmenter le nombre de seniors en
emploi et en même temps on nous dit si
on crée part un CDI senior ou peu
importe comment il s'appelle exactement
on passe à côté de l'élément essentiel
de cette réforme qui est absent
aujourd'hui du projet de loi donc déjà
est-ce qu'on pourrait peut-être se
mettre d'accord entre nous sur le fait
de dire que le recul de l'âge de départ
à la retraite ne crée pas d'emploi chez
les seniors puisque les républicains ont
eux-mêmes déposé un amendement pour
réparer ce qu'ils ont ce qu'il décrivait
comme pourtant étant déjà dans la
réforme ça c'est une première chose la
deuxième chose c'est que bon moi j'avais
pas ces chiffres en tête mais je les
crois bien volontiers notre collègue
vient de nous dire si on avait si on
corrigé l'écart de d'emploi des seniors
en France par rapport à la moyenne de
l'UE on aurait 13 milliards dans les
caisses c'est à dire en gros bien ce que
ce qu'on cherche c'est de l'ordre de 13
milliards qu'on cherche et on a un
dispositif qu'on nous propose qui
consiste à baisser des cotisations donc
à appauvrir les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale donc on marche sur la tête d'un
côté on nous dit cette réforme va
permettre d'augmenter l'emploi des
seniors mais comme elle ne le fait pas
on a besoin d'un outil qui va nous
permettre que l'emploi des seniors donne
moins dans les caisses de la Sécurité
sociale dont nous avons besoin pour
financer les retraites je veux dire à un
moment donné il y a un aspect de pure
cohérence intellectuelle qui m'échappe
totalement
[Musique]
on voit bien que cette proposition
d'une part fait le constat du fait que
ça va graver la situation des seniors
certes il y aura quelques créations de
prolongement mais le gros du paquet va
rester ni emploi ni
retraite et comme d'habitude la seule
idée qui vient à droite c'est que j'en
ai des cotisations sociales ça fait des
lustres
que vous avez des contrats de ceci
premier embauche dernier machin là ça va
être dernier embauche et l'efficacité je
m'excuse de dire c'est la bulle par
contre l'assèchement des comptes de la
protection sociale ça c'est du sérieux
alors
parlons des cotisations
s'il y avait l'égalité salariale femme
qui est peut-être quand même plus facile
à atteindre que de faire travailler des
gens qui pour une part sont dans des
situations très difficiles pour pouvoir
travailler on aurait déjà fait la moitié
de vos 13 milliards là on en serait à 6
ou 7
deuxièmement ça fait des années des
années qu'on explique que les
exonérations de cotisations sociales si
elles sont elles peuvent être
pertinentes elles ne le peuvent être
qu'à deux conditions la première c'est
qu'elle soit ciblée vers des activités
par exemple pour accompagner la
réindustrialisation l'évolution de la
tension inécologique etc et si elles
sont conditionnées c'est à dire s'il y a
des garanties au lieu de créer le énième
la énième cotisation allégée
exiger que pour avoir l’allègement
l'équivalent c'est du du contrat du
les allégements Hollande contrat bon
bref
c'est voilà merci la contrepartie de
l'équivalent ici soit conditionné un
accord ou à des engagements concernant
toute une série de critères dont
l'augmentation de la part des seniors là
vous ne faites pas dépenses
supplémentaires vous ciblez merci alors
je vais maintenant donner la parole il
n'y a plus de monde d'explication de
vote à Madame la rapporteur général
monsieur le Président Monsieur les
ministres chers collègues j'ai entendu
parler de concurrence entre les jeunes
et les vieux alors là c'est quelque
chose que que j'ai du mal à entendre
parce que je crois que alors je suis
peut-être idéaliste mais en réalité je
crois à l'utilité de chacun dans la
société il y a pas de mise en
concurrence de telles catégories
vis-à-vis de telle autre je pense qu'on
a dans ce pays parfois penser à des
politiques spécifiques pour les jeunes
on a moins pensé aux politiques
spécifiques pour les seniors c'est
dommage il y a quand même un territoire
le Val-de-Marne qui a pensé et nous
avons auditionné d'ailleurs les acteurs
de ce dispositif qui s'appelle label
plus 45 et c'était très intéressant de
les entendre parce que en réalité on
pourrait déployer ce type de dispositif
un petit peu partout c'est à dire
sensibiliser l'entreprise sensibilité la
population parce que comme je le disais
hier c'est notre société qui doit
changer de mentalité vis-à-vis de nos
aînés les aînés ont des choses à
transmettre les aînés ont des choses à
dire aux jeunes alors que on a de plus
en plus de d'apprentis dans notre dans
nos territoires on devrait justement
capitaliser si c'est un terme qui ne
vous plaît pas moi je pense qu'on peut
capitaliser sur le savoir des anciens et
donc un contrat tel que il est proposé
est aussi sur cette dimension là cette
idéale là de transmettre et de et de
permettre à nos seniors et bien
d'apporter aux jeunes une sorte de
tutorat de mantorat qui est utile alors
c'est vrai que ce contrat est sans doute
pas bien écrit et qui qu'il faut y
repenser mais il y a effectivement une
loi de travail qui qui arrive donc on
pourra le travailler ensemble si je puis
dire mais je voudrais reparler aussi de
l'index Seigneur parce que moi il me
semble que dans cette index Seigneur il
faudra penser dans la loi travail à y
mettre un bonus on toujours à parler de
punir punir punir mais on sait on peut
aussi dire quand c'est bien et quand on
valorise des bonnes initiatives et donc
dans l'index au Seigneur et bien il
faudra justement regarder comment on
peut mettre en avant les très bonnes
initiatives et je pense que des CDI vers
les seniors c'est une très belle
initiative
oui je voudrais juste deux trois près de
6 ans sans allonger les débats mais elle
me semble
indispensable non je ne suis pas
asservie au MEDEF à tel point que
j'accepte bien volontiers l'indicateur
je crois pas que ce soit le Medef qui
réclame l'indicateur mais permettez-moi
de vous dire que
j'ai des relations toujours respectueuse
avec les différents partenaires sociaux
que ce soit le medefo j'ai eu l'occasion
de rencontrer auditionné son secrétaire
général je rencontrais régulièrement
madame pizza puisqu'elle est présidente
de l'argile Carco et puis d'autres dans
le cadre du corps et Monique Lubin c'est
bien les discussions qu'on peut avoir au
niveau du corps on évite effectivement
de parler ce qu'il fâche sinon on en
sortirait pas une fois qu'on a dit ça on
peut parler d'autre chose et notamment
de l'employé habilité des seniors et
c'est comme ça que à force de discussion
est venue cette idée pas inventer si
vous voulez je voulais remettre un petit
peu
ça vous le dire en toute en toute
syntéricité donc indépendant de tout
cela vous voyez vous j'ai pas
effectivement écouter toutes les
propositions de tout j'en ai choisi
quelques-unes deuxièmement
il a été
dit à travers une intervention que il
fallait plutôt que s'occuper des seniors
au chômage qu'il fallait mieux s'occuper
des seniors en emploi oui aussi les
seigneurs en emploi c'est pour ça que
notamment vous êtes les premiers à
dénoncer ce qu'on dénonce aussi qu'il
faut prendre des mesures pour les maires
de famille et les mesures des mers de
famille qu'on va vous proposer c'est
effectivement parce que elle reste en
emploi un peu plus longtemps peut-être
avec l'effet de décalage de l'âge mais
surtout avec l'effet de la réforme
Touraine
meurent proposez pas d'être inhumain de
faire en sorte de vouloir
particulièrement mettre les seniors au
travail c'est l'application de la
réforme Touraine on travaille 43 ans
quand vous voyez vous avez commencé à 20
ans vous travaillez 43 ans mais quand
vous avez commencé à travailler à 22 ans
vous travaillez jusque Canac jusque 65
ans c'est la réforme Touraine l'effet
d'âge effectivement effectivement il
peut avoir aussi un effet mais je
voudrais qu'on soit clair entre nous
très clair entre nous
c'est pas 43 ans plus deux ans du au
travail supplémentaire soit disant de
soit 62 à 64 non non c'est l'ajustement
des bornes et effectivement de par la
réforme Touraine certains seront ou
certaines seront amenés à travailler
plus longtemps et d'autres par les faits
de l'âge légal seront à travailler
quelques mois également plus longtemps
peut-être pour certaines générations
mais c'est pas deux ans de plus pour
tout le monde arrêtez de vendre un
argument qui est faux parce
qu'effectivement ça contribue à mettre
les gens dans la rue mais si on leur
explique bien
la différence elle est quand même
importante
[Applaudissements]
voilà donc je ne suis pas le bourreau
des seniors que vous prétendez que je
sois ensuite effectivement il y a eu il
y a eu des propositions de la belle
Jean-Marie varaner un garçon sage
Jean-Marie connais bien le dispositif il
connaît bien les syndicats et il est pas
asservé non plus à un syndicat mais ne
connaît bien ben écoutez moi je partage
aussi ça un index à pénalise un label ça
valorise bon on peut peut-être trouver
un équilibre entre les deux
[Applaudissements]
merci monsieur le Président très
rapidement je veux pas contribuer à
allonger les débats je pense qu'on a été
suffisamment éclairé mais je voudrais
répondre à quelques points qui ont été
évoqués qui peuvent je pense être utile
dans les choix que les uns et les autres
feront au moment du vote si l'amendement
n'est pas retiré d'abord pour répondre à
Monsieur Vandenberg je vous rejoins
totalement
sur la question du taux d'emploi si on
avait le même taux d'emploi en France
que nos voisins allemands moi j'aurais
pas de travail j'en aurai beaucoup moins
pour équilibrer les comptes puisque les
recettes supplémentaires induites par 10
points de taux d'emploi en plus nous
permettrait d'équilibrer ou en tout cas
d'équilibrer beaucoup mieux nos budgets
donc la question c'est comment est-ce
qu'on améliore le taux d'emploi
améliorer le taux d'emploi ça veut dire
travailler sur les jeunes et c'est donc
tout ce qu'on a fait notamment sur
l'apprentissage ce qu'on doit faire sur
la réforme du lycée professionnel qui
aujourd'hui objectivement ne permet pas
d'insérer véritablement les jeunes dans
l'emploi et donc c'est une réforme qui
est particulièrement importante et deux
sur les seniors et donc oui on doit
s'interroger collectivement sur les
mesures les plus efficaces pour
améliorer le taux d'emploi des seniors
et c'est vrai et je réponds à Madame
Vogel notamment c'est vrai que la
réforme de 2010 a permis une
amélioration du taux d'emploi des
seniors de 15 points depuis 2010 toutes
les études qui ont été réalisées le
disent il y a pas eu besoin de contrats
spécifiques après la réforme Fillon de
2010 pour améliorer de 15 points le taux
d'emploi des seniors mais évidemment
qu'on doit penser à des mesures
supplémentaires il y a l'index il peut y
en avoir d'autres moi j'ai entendu le
rapporteur général comme Monsieur
vanderenberg dire que ce dispositif de
CDI senior était peut-être pas le mieux
abouti donc moi je proposerai volontiers
de retirer cet amendement et qu'on
retravaille les choses peut-être en vue
de la loi travail ou du prochain PLFSS
moi encore une fois prendre une mesure
qui coûterait 800 millions d'euros à la
branche famille sans qu'on est de
garantie sur son efficacité vous avez
parlé de Paris mais je suis pas
totalement convaincu et pour répondre à
Monsieur Retailleau l'effet d'aubaine ça
serait si toutes les entreprises qui ont
actuellement un contrat avec un seigneur
de plus de 60 ans de transformer en CDI
seniors là ça serait 2 milliards 300
millions d'euros donc c'est pas ça dont
je parle quand je parle des 800 millions
d'euros le coût de 800 millions d'euros
c'est le coût pour les seniors qui
aujourd'hui rentrent dans un contrat
après 60 ans vous en avez 100000 à peu
près chaque année qui sont recrutés on
imagine assez bien qu'un chef
d'entreprise qui recrute un seigneur qui
a plus de 60 ans il a le choix entre le
CDI classique sans allègement de
cotisation sur la branche famille et le
CDI senior où il a 5 points de
cotisation en moins sur les cotisations
familles il va plutôt choisir le CDI
senior donc d'ores et déjà pour les
seniors qui sont aujourd'hui recrutés
sans dispositif sans qui ai besoin
dispositif supplémentaires ça coûte 800
millions d'euros donc peut-être qu'il y
en aura d'autres qui le seront à ce
moment-là en plus mais enfin il en
faudrait beaucoup pour que ça compense
les faits avant de conclure je veux
juste revenir sur la question des
allègements et des exonérations de
cotisation ça a été abordé et j'ai
entendu parler notamment monsieur
kerouge de dualité dans le discours etc
il y a eu depuis 20 ans deux grandes
étapes d'allègement de cotisations pour
les entreprises
la première de ces deux grandes étapes
depuis 20 ans c'est le PLFSS 2014
présenté à l'époque de François Hollande
avec notamment les allègements et les
exonérations maladie et familles pour 25
milliards d'euros 25 milliards d'euros
dans le plfs 2014 je suis allé regarder
j'ai demandé à mon équipe de Me
ressortir le scrutin public de l'époque
l'intégralité du groupe socialiste à
l'époque avait voté la mesure
d'exonération de 25 milliards d'euros de
cotisations maladie et famille à
l'exception de trois sénateurs je les
cite quand même madame linman qui à
l'époque n'avait pas souhaité le voter
et Monsieur Godefroy et monsieur daudini
qui ne sont ne siège plus mais le groupe
socialiste à l'époque avait voté 25
milliards d'euros de baisse de
cotisations pour les entreprises ensuite
la deuxième étape c'est la
transformation du cice en baisse de
cotisation 2019 Emmanuel Macron
président de la République ce qui est
intéressant de regarder c'est qu'entre
avant la transformation du cice en
baisse de cotisation et aujourd'hui
on perçoit aujourd'hui 21 milliards de
recettes en plus pour la sécurité
sociale parce que comme on a baissé les
cotisations il y a plus d'embauches un
million 500000 de plus et donc on
perçoit aujourd'hui plus de recettes
puisqu'il y a plus de personnes qui
travaillent pour la sécurité sociale
donc oui alléger les cotisations a
permis d'élargir le nombre de
recrutement et donc d'avoir des recettes
supplémentaires pour la sécu donc pour
ces raisons-là c'est pour ça que je dis
j'ai pas de tabou sur la question des
baisses de cotisations merci monsieur
lui allons passer maintenant vote nous
avons commencé par l'amendement 4741
madame Dubos ceux qui sont favorables
sur l'adoption manifeste en levant la
main
avis contraire
attention il n'est pas adopté
un sous-amendement qui a été présenté
par
Monsieur Dufour madame guidez il est
maintenu
il est pas maintenu merci Madame
présenté par Madame Lubin ceux qui sont
pour
je pense que nous avons le même vote
pour le suivant
il est et le suivant aussi il est ils ne
sont pas adoptés et nous allons passer
au vote par scrutin public demander par
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologiste de l'amendement de la
commission du porteur numéro 21 et les
sénateurs sont donc en train de voter
sur le CDI senior c'est la proposition
que fait la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat dans cette réforme des
retraites sur la question de l'emploi
des seniors ce CDI senior consiste en
des contrats pour les salariés de plus
de 60 ans demandeurs d'emploi des
contrats avec une exonération de
cotisations sur la branche famille de la
sécurité sociale le but c'est d'inciter
les entreprises à embaucher des salariés
de plus de 60 ans alors qu'on sait que
justement le taux de chômage se creuse
pour cette catégorie de la population
alors le gouvernement a émis un avis
défavorable car il estime que cette
mesure est trop coûteuse notamment pour
la sécurité social avec cette
exonération de charge sur la branche
famille et la gauche a dénoncé cette
politique d'exonération de cotisation
sociale pour favoriser l'emploi car elle
estime que cela va affaiblir les
finances de la sécurité sociale donc les
sénateurs qui sont en train de voter
parce scrutin public ça veut dire que
chaque vote de chaque sénateur sera
rendu public notamment sur le site
internet du Sénat le vote qui est en
train d'être finalisé et les résultats à
adopter
et donc le Sénat a adopté ce CDI senior
pour favoriser l'emploi des seniors et
justement pour en parler on va retrouver
Quentin Calmet en tribune de presse de
l'hémicycle du Sénat Quentin vous avez
suivi avec attention ces débats ce matin
des débats de haute qualité sur ce sujet
du CDI senior quelles ont été à les
temps forts et les différentes positions
autour de cette proposition vous le
disiez Alexandre c'est une mesure portée
par la droite sénatoriale René Paul
Savary leur apportant de la branche
vieillesse du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale ici au
Sénat une mesure donc qui n'avait pas
été examinée par les députés lors de
leur lecture à l'Assemblée nationale la
droite qui est le centre qui propose
donc un CDI senior calqué sur le
principe d'un CDI de chantier pour une
mission de fin de carrière dans une
entreprise un CDI qui vient donc d'être
adopté un rajouter au projet de loi de
réforme des retraites pour leur
apporteur LR il s'agit de par exemple
faire du tutorat dans l'entreprise avec
donc des exonérations de cotisations
familles écouter René PA
ont été retirés la gauche est
extrêmement sceptique c'est le moins que
l'on puisse dire sur cette mesure elle a
voté contre dans l'hémicycle mais donc
n'a pas remporté ce vote Monique Lubin a
ainsi dit pour les socialistes cela nous
paraît être un outil pour recruter des
gens que finalement on garde le moins
possible même chose pour Bernard gomier
qui s'est opposé lui aussi pour les
socialistes en disant ces exonérations
de cotisations familles elles n'ont pas
de sens il faut maintenir ses
cotisations qui financent notre modèle
social écouter pour les communistes
Fabien gay quand on a reporté l'âge
légal de 60 à 62 ans ça a été nul sur
l'embauche des settiors qui n'était pas
au travail nul et donc les 1 million
quatre de personnes qui sont entre 53 et
69 ans qui sont aujourd'hui sans emploi
ni revenus il y aura pas plus d'embauche
avec ce contrat dernier embauche et le
gouvernement de son côté était également
opposé à cette mesure pour de multiples
raisons mais par exemple et bien GAB a
dit que s'il y avait un danger avec des
effets de seuil avec cet âge à 60 ans ou
ce CDI senior serait possible le risque
c'est qu'on décale le problème aux gens
juste avant 60 ans écouter le Miss des
comptes publics moi je suis toujours
assez sceptique sur des propositions
d'allègement de cotisation ciblées sur
un âge donné le risque c'est qu'on
décale le problème et que c'est que des
personnes qui aujourd'hui en plus 60 ans
et sont au chômage en fait on décale le
problème à ceux qui sont juste avant 60
ans parce que eux n'auront pas droit à
l'exonération pour leur employeur s'ils
sont recrutés ça c'est la première chose
sur la deuxième chose c'est un
amendement qui coûte effectivement
une certaine somme voilà et le ministre
également de dénoncer le coût de la
mesure qui est chiffré à 800 millions
d'euros voilà Alex ce CDI senior qui
vient donc d'être adopté 200 de voix
pour 123 voies contre par le Sénat merci
beaucoup Quentin et on va tout de suite
et bien continuer à suivre les débats
sur la réforme des retraites dans cycle
du Sénat il y a certainement des choses
à regarder et à pousser qui peuvent être
travaillés différemment d'abord avec des
outils d'accompagnement du mentorat nous
avons un plan alors il y a souvent des
plans qu'on articule autour d'un jeune
et une solution sur un porteur proposé
hier de dire un seigneur une solution
mais nous avons aussi un plan sur le
mentorat qui nous permet de passer de 20
000 opérations de mon temps par an et de
20000 jeunes mentorés à 200000 et cette
montée en charge nous y arrivons sans
qu'il y ait nécessité de mettre en place
un contrat particulier pour inciter au
mentorat il y a une deuxième raison qui
en fait qu'un peu plus loin dans le
texte nous aurons l'occasion d'examiner
ce que nous proposons en matière de
retraite progressive indépendamment des
quelques différences de d'ambition de
perception que nous avons avec la
commission de l'affaire sociale nous
voulons simplifier l'accès à la retraite
progressive et nous considérons que
faciliter l'accès à la retraite
progressive pour les employeurs c'est
une manière de diminuer le temps de
travail dont ils ont à leur charge et
donc de faciliter le redéploiement de
ces personnes sur du mentorat et de la
formation donc pour a pas de raison
c'est une demande de retrait avec la
perspic la perspective de la loi travail
qui nous permettra d'avancer mais je le
répète la montée en puissance du
mentorat nous y arrivons sans contrat
donc travaillons ensemble pour faire en
sorte que ce soit encore plus
effectivement madame de chaîne
oui merci monsieur le Président au vu de
vous expliquer monsieur le ministre je
veux je vais retirer cet amendement mais
quand même ça favorise l'esprit
d'entreprise la transmission des
savoir-faire ça me semble
particulièrement important et je serai
attentive au moment d'une loi travail
pour que ce dispositif puisse être
amélioré et repris il est retiré un
amendement qui porte le numéro 42
qui le reprend
madame linman
parce que ce débat mérite d'être d'être
engagé on passe notre temps à nous
expliquer que la seule façon pour que
dans le travail dans l'entreprise ça va
nous ramener au traite quand la seule
façon dans l'entreprise c'est de donner
des allégements de cotisation pour faire
ce qui est toujours fait normalement
dans une entreprise c'est-à-dire que les
plus anciens les plus compétents au
konja qui des compétences les
transmettre aux autres et c'est bien le
débat s'il y a une telle pression sur
les salariés si elle est salarié sont
devenus de moins en moins des acteurs
d'une communauté humaine qui est
l'entreprise maintenant tout le monde
est sous pression sous tension n'a pas
le temps de faire vivre cette
transmission d'incompétence et on croit
qu'avec un allègement de cotisation on
va pouvoir régler ce problème un ça va
être des effets d'aubaine 2 ça
n'améliorera le mentorat qui doit être
fondé sur un certain volontarré
volontariat et donc pour ma part je suis
totalement opposée à cet amendement et
puisque je l'ai repris je le retire il
est retiré bon donc non on cesse de
jouer avec ça et donc poursuivons par
l'examen du l'amendement 4260 rectifié
monsieur Bocquet
excusez-nous monsieur le Président j'ai
vu qu'il y avait de la concurrence mais
je suis ravi
nous souhaitons par cet amendement
augmenter la pénalité financière des
entreprises qui ne respectent pas leur
obligation en matière d'égalité
professionnelle et notamment en matière
d'écart entre de rémunération entre les
hommes et les femmes chacun le sait ici
les inégalités que les femmes subissent
au travail se répercutent sur leurs
droits à la retraite et de statistiques
en rapport le constat est sans appel les
inégalités perdues durant la période
d'activité au point et se répercute je
viens de le dire sur la retraite au
point que le taux de pauvreté des femmes
retraités et supérieure à celui des
hommes 10,4
la droite notamment par l'amendement de
Madame de scène proposait de créer un
contrat de mentorat qui donc serait
aligné sur celui du CDI senior mais pour
favoriser le mentorat la gauche et donc
la sénatrice a retiré son amendement la
gauche a décidé de le reprendre ce qui
est permis par le Règlement du Sénat
quelque chose qui n'existe pas par
exemple nationale lorsque un sénateur
décide de retirer son amendement un
autre sénateur peut décider de le
reprendre et donc madame linman a repris
cette amendement mais pour le dénoncer à
ce moment-là et donc le retirer à
nouveau ce qui avait lu ces
applaudissements de la gauche à ce
moment-là
représente aujourd'hui 19% des emplois
contre 10 il y a 30 ans donc nous
voulons mettre fin à ces inégalités qui
se répercutent sur la retraite
d'autant que ces contrats à temps
partiel
accroisse la pression sur chacune ou
chacun des salariés qu'il exerce puisque
bien souvent ça se traduit par faire
plus de travail en moins de temps qu'un
temps complet le permettrait et donc ça
use davantage et donc c'est un double
effet négatif sur les retraites et ça
rend encore plus une excès inacceptable
le recul de l'âge de départ de deux ans
je vous remercie je vais demander la vie
de la Commission et la vie du
gouvernement je signale que je suis de
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par le groupe communiste républicain
citoyen oui merci effectivement
vous proposez
d'accroître les pénalités en ce qui
concerne cet index il n'était pas publié
ou s'il pas évolutif dans une période de
trois ans mais vous pouvez vous proposer
à la fois d'augmenter les pénalités et
de réduire le délai à un an de mise en
conformité en tout cas en l'absence
d'action significative pour faire en
sorte d'améliorer l'inégalité entre les
hommes et les femmes c'est notre
réflexion en ce qui concerne la
commission des affaires sociales à plus
haut penser que il existait déjà des
bases légales très précises en ce qui
concerne l'index homme-femme
contrairement à l'index senior et en
conséquence nous pensons que ce n'est
pas nécessaire appliquons déjà le
dispositif actuel impliquant les
pénalités si besoin et laissons trois
ans pour se mettre en conformité et là
si c'est pas mis en conformité
effectivement peut être accroître les
pénalités merci merci monsieur le
ministre de vous être emparé de ce
slogan que nous à la commission des
affaires sociales à faire un plan
similaire c'était un jeune une solution
ça apportait ses fruits ça a changé un
petit peu la vision par rapport aux
emplois des jeunes c'est significatif
mais écoutez on pourrait essayer de
décliner à la bourre au moment de la fin
de carrière ce passage entre la partie
active et la sédentarité à travers
effectivement des dispositions madame
liemann qui permettrait à travers un CDI
senior de faire du tutorat améliorer
bien entendu mais faire du tutorat et
faire véritablement un seigneur une
solution si tout le monde s'empare du
dispositif et bien on aura servi à
quelque chose Monsieur le Ministre
merci monsieur le Président c'est une
demande de retrait ou à vous suivez en
direct le débat entre les sénateurs sur
cette réforme des retraites et pour en
parler j'accueille sur ce plateau Fabien
gay bonjour bonjour vous êtes sénateur
communiste de Seine-Saint-Denis à la
droite il y a quelques minutes la droite
et le centre du Sénat viennent de voter
ce qu'ils appellent le CDI senior c'est
à dire un contrat pour inciter les
entreprises à embaucher plus de seniors
notamment à partir de 60 ans pourquoi
cette opposition de la gauche dans ce
débat alors que c'est plutôt une mesure
pour favoriser l'emploi non ça
favorisera pas du tout l'emploi vous
savez ça m'a rappelé mon engagement en
politique en 2006 j'ai manifesté avec
des millions de de personnes et beaucoup
de jeunes contre le Contrat Première
Embauche qui était déjà destiné à
embaucher les jeunes avec des
exonérations massives de cotisations
sociales c'est exactement la même chose
c'est un contrat dernier embauche qu'on
nous propose avec des exonérations de
cotisations une nouvelle fois qui ne
fonctionne pas j'ai rappelé d'ailleurs
dans l'hémicycle le rapport sur le cice
vous savez c'est 20 milliards d'euros de
cotisations on nous promettait avec
François Hollande oui avec un badge vous
rappelez pierre Gattaz 1 million
d'emplois ça crée 100000 emplois ça fait
cher quand même pour 18 milliards chaque
année c'est 180000 euros de subventions
à l'emploi quand le salaire médian et
aux alentours chargé de cotisation 33000
vous voyez donc ça ne marche pas on sait
que les exonérations n'ont pas besoin de
démultiplier les CDI les CDD les
contrats dernière embauche si on veut
agir sur l'emploi alors il y a besoin de
d'agir avec les entreprises et les
contraintes par la loi vous n'y
arriverez pas avec des exonérations
massives ça ne fonctionne pas et
d'ailleurs la dernière chose c'est que
le ministral a eu raison on va scier là
aussi la branche famille de la sécurité
sociale c'est 3 à 4 milliards d'euros de
côté d'exonération de cotisations qui va
compenser l'État
vous allez avoir sur plusieurs trois
quatre trois quatre milliards à trouver
sur cinq ans peut-être que sur les cinq
premières années l'État exonérat et
après compensera pardon et après donc
c'est une très mauvaise mesure elle ne
fonctionne pas elle a prouvé son
inefficacité et en plus vous allez
encore mettre un coup terrible à la
sécurité sociale Fabien on va parler de
la journée de demain le 7 mars avec cet
appel à des syndicats des syndicats qui
veulent je cite mettre la France à
l'arrêt beaucoup de grève dans tout le
pays et puis ici au Sénat ce sera
normalement avec un accord entre les
différents groupes politiques et bien ce
sera le moment de débattre de l'article
7 de la référence de la retraite on
verra on verra mais c'est ce qu'il se
dit en tout cas en tout cas de débattre
de l'article 7 sur le report de l'âge
légal de départ à 64 ans ce serait
important justement que les sénateurs
débattent de cet article 7 demain soir
après une prestation nous nous toujours
dit depuis le début il faut en venir au
vote sur l'article 7 d'abord le débat et
que chacun il n'y a pas une bonne
position mais que chacun puisse par un
vote signifie s'il veut reporter l'âge
légal de 62 à 60 ans vous le savez pour
le groupe communiste républicain citoyen
écologistes non et donc demain nous on
est ravis de cette journée on sera un
pied dans la rue aux côtés du mouvement
social un pied dans l'hémicycle
évidemment pour continuer à combattre ce
projet de contre-réforme mais oui il
faut en venir à l'article 7 on verra si
c'est demain on verra si c'est mercredi
on verra si c'est peut-être jeudi peu
importe nous on ne fait pas
d'obstruction la seule obstruction qu'il
y a ici c'est une obstruction
silencieuse de la part de la droite qui
ne refuse de débattre nous on avance et
on en viendra l'article 7 comme ça sera
le temps mais il faudrait que la gauche
peut-être retire certains amendements
pour arriver demain plus vite il
faudrait surtout que la droite arrête
cette obstruction silencieuse et
débattre parce que pour un débat
monsieur Poussard x 2
vous débattez tout seul et que je
réponds aucune question il y a pas
d'interview mais voyez un débat
parlementaire c'est pareil il faut être
deux donc la gauche elle elle agit
tranquillement on avance un certain
nombre d'arguments je crois que depuis
le début personne peut dire qu'il y a eu
des arguments un peu un peu fou on
avance et il faut que la droite débatte
à nous que les ministres répondent et
puis on est en arrivera tranquillement
l'article 7 qu'est-ce que vous attendez
de cette journée de manifestation et de
grève demain c'est le début du blocage
du pays ah bah écoutez beaucoup et je
sais que ça va être énorme on le voit
partout dans les grandes villes dans les
villages dans les sous-préfecture
partout sur le territoire des dizaines
des centaines de points sont annoncés de
de manifestations la grève doit être
massive dans les transports à EDF je
tiens les saluer ils ont commencé des
week-end à reprendre leur routier
industriel en main dans le privé dans le
public un certain nombre de
collectivités seront fermés parce que
tous les fonctionnaires seront en grève
et il faut que les mobilisations et les
manifestations soient le plus massif bon
mais nous ça va nous donner du baume au
coeur et je vous je vous avoue on attend
le 7 avait très grande et passion je
suis pas sûr que les ministres ou la
droite sénatoriale soit dans le même
état d'esprit nous on est très heureux
mais ça donnera du baume au coeur à la
gauche pour les débats demain sur
l'article 7 le report de l'âge légal de
départ à 64 ans et ce sera à suivre et
bien en direct sur public c'est d'aller
on retourne dans l'hémicycle ou les
sénateurs continuent à débattre de cette
réforme des retraites dans ce genre de
situation merci
monsieur le Président donc si je partage
le constat qui a été fait sur les bancs
jusqu'à l'instant je partage pas la
position sur la demandement oui
aujourd'hui il y a des inégalités
salariales oui il y a des inégalités de
carrière oui nous avons tenté de
diminuer ces inégalités à travers
différents textes et notamment la
proposition de loi que nous qui est
devenue loi sur l'égalité économique et
professionnelle donc il y a des outils
mais on ne va pas réussir à finalement
corriger toutes ces inégalités dont font
l'objet des femmes à travers un projet
de loi sur les retraites c'est en
réalité on utilise un projet de loi sur
les retraites pour corriger des
carrières or les carrières et bien c'est
évidemment une loi travail c'est
évidemment des propositions à faire sur
sur la réglementation sur
l'accompagnement des femmes et des
parcours de femmes donc oui pour le
constat non pour le vote sur
l'amendement je vous remercie
je pense merci monsieur le Président je
pense précisément qu'une réforme des
retraites juste devrait se donner pour
priorité de corriger les inégalités en
matière de différence quand même
extrêmement important de retraite entre
les hommes et les femmes et je le redis
c'est différent elle s'explique par les
carrières et les emplois qui sont
occupés par les uns et par les autres
prenons les aesh et je sais madame la
présente de la délégation que vous
connaissez bien le sujet ce sont ah je
crois 90% des femmes avec des contrats
qui sont souvent de moins de 24 heures
semaine avec des salaires qui
n'atteignent même pas les 900 euros si
je prends des caissières de supermarché
elles ont elles aussi souvent des
contrats à temps extrêmement partiels si
on prend les salariés qui travaillent
dans tout le secteur de l'entretien avec
des amplitudes horaires phénoménales
et bien je pense qu'il faut que nous
soyons plus volontariste et que les
outils que nous développons soient
beaucoup plus ferme pour corriger cela
parce que vous savez il y a de multiples
choses qui mettent les gens dans la rue
en ce moment et certains ont nous ont
fait l'honneur de croire que nous en
étions quasiment les uniques
responsables mais une des premières
choses qui a mis des gens dans la rue
est particulièrement des femmes c'est la
non volonté de corriger ces inégalités
il y a énormément de femmes dans les
cortèges et je pense que chacun serait
bien intentionné de les écouter il n'y a
pas de recette miracle et effectivement
les dispositifs vont mettre du temps à
faire leur effet mais si on se dit bon
bah les choses avancent après tout ça
fera son effet le moment viendra ou
enfin l'égalité sera là je crois qu'on
est vraiment en dessous de la réalité de
l'aspiration des femmes
oui merci monsieur le Président moi il y
a quelque chose qui m'étonne toujours y
compris dans cette émission c'est quand
des collègues ou des ministres au bord
du gouvernement nous disent mais ça
commence à faire effet on est en 2023 il
y a toujours pas d'égalité
professionnelle malgré les nombreuses
lois qui ont été votées il y a pas
d'amélioration réelle des conditions de
travail et pas non plus des conditions
de retraite et messieurs les ministres
avec votre réforme vous allez encore
aggraver les choses vous allez aggraver
les choses et à tel point d'ailleurs que
toutes les associations féministes tous
les syndicats sont vend debout sur cette
réforme et particulièrement sur le sort
qui est réservé aux femmes quand on ne
prend pas en compte le fait que ce sont
elles et ça a été dit par mes collègues
qui ont des carrières hachées qui ont
une pénibilité dans de nombreux métiers
maximum on parle effectivement des des
travailleurs et des travailleurs
première de corvées lors notamment de la
covid on les a applaudis au gouvernement
aussi vous les avez applaudis mais ça a
été quoi après les conséquences qui ont
été tirées pour améliorer les choses
aucune et quand vous osez prendre comme
référence l'index sur l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes pour essayer
hier de nous faire passer la pilule sur
l'index des seniors c'est quand même de
l'enfumage pourquoi c'est de l'enfumage
parce que l'index pour l'égalité entre
les femmes et les hommes est totalement
insuffisant et vous ne nous écoutez pas
vous ne nous entendez pas vous refusez
de nous entendre ici dans l'hémicycle
mais aussi dans la rue et c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs demain la mobilisation va
être extrêmement forte et c'est une
bonne nouvelle pour tout le monde c'est
une bonne nouvelle parce que ça va
peut-être faire bouger les choses mais
là encore vous préférez dialoguer entre
vous plutôt que d'entendre la
représentation parlementaire
pour régler le problème mais madame
billon oui c'est un problème de recettes
parce que vous vous nous expliquez qu'on
est obligé de travailler jusqu'à 60
avant l'âge égal à 64 parce que
globalement on a un trou dans la honoré
un déficit mais il n'aurait pas de
difficile si le niveau des salaires
étaient meilleurs si niveau des salaires
des femmes étaient égales à celui des
hommes il y aurait pas de déficit si si
vous vous payez correctement les métiers
d'ailleurs dans la simulation qui a été
faite sur les sur les retraites il a été
prévu que dans la fonction publique ni
embauche et gel du point d'indice or les
femmes les infirmières les professeurs
le nombre important de femmes dans les
collectivités locales vous n'allez pas
augmenter leur salaire vous n'allez pas
revaloriser leur métier et vous allez en
creuser les caisses de retraite et nous
faire travailler ou de la
oui merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
les ministres mes chers collègues on
sait que la retraite c'est le refret de
la vie à la fois de des inégalités de la
vie mais aussi peut-être des promesses
ou en tout cas de ce qui n'a pas pu être
tenu dans une vie et je trouve que ce
débat que nous avons aujourd'hui
en tout cas par l'amendement que je
salue de Madame Brulin et est
intéressante parce que finalement à
celles et ceux qui disent mais ne vous
inquiétez pas ça avance finalement on va
réussir aujourd'hui en 2023 c'était car
de 40% est absolument énorme
on ne peut pas s'en satisfaire et on le
sait bien alors pourquoi refuser des
dispositifs qui vont permettre de
contraindre un peu plus ou en tout cas
de faire pousser un peu plus ces
inégalités je trouve que aujourd'hui
quand on parle des femmes et Madame
Brulin l'a dit on sait que le taux de
pauvreté est plus élevé 10,4% pour les
femmes quand il n'est que de 8,5% pour
les hommes et un dernier chiffre qui est
imparable c'est que l'écart entre le
taux de pauvreté moyen des femmes et des
hommes retraités a tendance oui mes
chers collègues à se creuser depuis 2012
puisque aujourd'hui nous sommes à 1,9
points en 2019 alors qu'il n'était que
de 0,6 points en 2012 donc vraiment je
trouve que c'est important et je vaut
très cette amendement bien nous allons
procéder
au scrutin public
le scrutin est ouvert
elle est sénateurs sont donc en train de
voter sur une proposition d'amendements
de la gauche d'imposer des pénalités
financières aux entreprises qui ne
respecteraient pas l'égalité de
rémunération entre les hommes et les
femmes l'égalité de rémunération
professionnelle en amendement défendu
sur tous les bancs des groupes
politiques de gauche on a entendu les
communistes les socialistes défendre
cette mesure restrictive pour les
entreprises pour essayer de favoriser
l'égalité salariale entre les femmes et
les hommes on est donc dans un scrutin
public ça veut dire que chaque sénateur
est en train de voter sur sa tablette
électronique et qu'au final son vote sur
cette amendement concernant l'égalité
salariale entre les femmes et les hommes
sont votes sera rendu public voilà pour
cette matinée ici au Sénat le vote est
clos on va entendre le résultat
alors que résultat votre temps 344
exprimé 332 pour 91 contre 241 de Sénat
n'a pas adopté et nous passons
à l'amendement
3219 madame poncemont je le présente il
y a sous forme d'amendement qui vont
faire l'objet d'une discussion commune
merci monsieur le Président alors il
s'agit par cet amendement
d'obliger les entreprises à publier des
indicateurs relatifs à la continuité des
carrières si vous voulez une poursuite
des parcours professionnels sans rupture
en effet les personnes ayant des
carrières hachées sont pénalisés
notamment lors de leur départ à la
retraite et la présente loi ici agrave
ce phénomène par l'accélération de la
durée requise pour avoir un temps plein
et oui monsieur le rapporteur ce qui est
d'une brutalité inédite c'est bien la
synergie des deux paramètres c'est à
dire des mesures d'âge et là c'est
toujours la droite qui les a voté et
aussi effectivement de la durée requise
donc qui appartient un certes à Madame
Touraine mais l'accélération c'est vous
selon
l'adresse je dirais pour mieux
comprendre d'ailleurs cela c'est qu'il y
a une personne qui est commune
à ces deux assez de vote c'est quand
même monsieur Macron qui était déjà dans
l'équipe qu'il avait très bien inspiré
selon selon l'adresse 32% des retraités
de la génération 50 ont une carrière
incomplète alors il est normal que les
personnes ayant des carrières hachées
perçoivent des retraites plus faibles
enfin c'est pas que c'est normal c'est
que c'est c'est logique en 2016 les
carrières incomplètes représentent 60%
des personnes qui bénéficient d'un
minimum de pension du régime général
les carrières hachées obligent de
nombreuses femmes à liquider tardivement
leurs droits à la retraite et les oblige
à poursuivre jusqu'à 67 ans elles sont
20% contre 10% des hommes âge de la fin
de l'application de la décote et cela ne
les préserve pas pour autant d'une
retraite faible c'est simplement la
double peine qui s'arrête à 67 ans
l'amendement 25 23 monsieur le Président
gonta oui merci Monsieur le monsieur le
Président cet amendement instaure dans
toutes les entreprises depuis 300
salariés des indicateurs de continuité
de carrière ces indicateurs et leurs
méthodes de calcul sont définies par
décret peuvent être complétés par
convention par accord de branche
l'amendement prévoit enfin des pénalités
financières pour les entreprises qui ne
respecteraient pas ces obligations ces
indicateurs en plus plusieurs objectifs
le premier renforcer la prise de
conscience des entreprises sur le fléau
que représente les carrières hachées
subies et les inciter donc à faire des
efforts assurer la transparence des
pratiques de chaque entreprise auprès
des partenaires sociaux des
administrations d’état et du public
octroyez au pouvoir public les données
précieuses leur permettant d'agir en
conséquence les carrières hachées
touchent majoritairement des femmes
exerçant dans des métiers pénibles les
temps partiels sont souvent imposées aux
femmes dans des métiers précaires et le
texte ne s'attaque absolument pas à ce
phénomène or notre système de retraite
est pensé sur le modèle des carrières
des hommes le retrait de son calcul et
deux facteurs salaires et durée de
Carrière Or les femmes ont des carrières
plus courtes ou des salaires plus
faibles que c'est des hommes les
différentes études le montrent les
femmes se retirent souvent de l'emploi
pour prendre en charge les enfants ou
pour prendre soin d'un parent malade ou
dépendant une femme sur deux réduit ou
arrête complètement son activité
professionnelle à l'arrivée d'un enfant
c'est le cas d'un homme sur neuf
résultats les femmes entre 25 et 54 ans
ont un taux d'activités de 8 points
inférieurs à celui des hommes 84% contre
92%. cumuler aux inégalités salaires la
conséquence des carrières hachées et
triple des pensions plus faibles le
montant dépensions de droit direct est
inférieur de 40% à celui versé aux
hommes même après le versement de la
pension réversion les femmes perçoivent
une pension inférieure de 28% à celle
des hommes par ailleurs 37% des femmes
de retraite touche moins de 1000 euros
de pension brutes un taux plein
difficilement atteint seul 60% des
femmes partent à la retraite à taux
plein contre 68% des hommes des départs
plus tardifs à la retraite en moyenne 6
mois plus tard
merci l'amendement suivant qui le
présente Madame Monsieur Breuillet
non je sens que vous êtes en concurrence
35003 oui oui monsieur le Président je
vais
beaucoup de choses que je voulais dire
ont été dites donc je vais essayer de
dire ce qui n'a pas été dit alors
effectivement c'est ce sont des
amendements relatifs à l'impact des
carrières hachées qui touche ça a été
dit ça par contre majoritairement les
femmes et je voudrais peut-être que
c'est par construction sociale et non de
façon innée mais pas construction
sociale les femmes effectivement sont
renvoyées au métier du prendre soin les
femmes se retirent souvent de l'emploi
pour prendre en charge les enfants ou
pour prendre en charge un parent malade
ou dépendant les aidants les fameuses
aidants qui vont faire l'objet de
d'un amendement effectivement sont
essentiellement des femmes
et une femme sur deux réduit arrête
complètement son activité
professionnelle ou arrête professionnel
à l'arrivée d'un enfant c'est le cas
d'un homme seulement sur neuf et ils en
profite pour dire qu'il faudra
accompagner une évolution sociale quand
même un peu trop lente on va pas
attendre trois siècles quand même que
pour que les femmes soient moins comme
ça assignés aux tâches du prendre soin
donc il faudra accompagner cette
évolution sociétale avec d'autres
réformes et nous vous proposerons
notamment plus tard un changement
législatif sur le congé paternel
post-natal qui soit allongé parce que
c'est peut-être à ce moment-là que les
comportements y compris tout au long de
la vie pour s'occuper après de quelqu'un
de malade ou de quelqu'un d'une personne
âgée en perte d'autonomie si dès le
départ dès le la naissance le congé
paternel post
j'ai fini alors voilà j'ai dit des
choses différentes je vous remercie
monsieur Breuillet
ici monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre monsieur les ministres
collègues c'est amendement déposé par
mon collègue dessus n'est pas concurrent
il a effectivement totalement
complémentaire et cohérent avec ceux qui
viennent défendus pour les femmes c'est
effectivement la triple peine inégalité
salariale inégalité des pensions
inégalités du temps de travail et les
chiffres en témoignent ils sont
dramatiques à l'heure actuelle une femme
sur cinq est contrainte de travailler
jusqu'à 67 ans pour bénéficier d'une
retraite à taux plein contre un homme
sur dix les carrières des femmes sont
généralement hachées et c'est la raison
de cet amendement d'appel parce qu'elles
sont socialisées au travail du Caire
lorsqu’un de leurs parents devient
malade ou dépendant lorsqu'elles ont un
enfant les femmes sont celles qui en
général quittent leur emploi et
travaillent à temps partiel et c'est
inégalité ne doit pas perdurer dans le
temps force est de constater que la
réforme n'améliore pas cette situation
des femmes peut-être d'ailleurs parce
que encore une fois le gouvernement
choisi un véhicule un juste et
inapproprié un petit véhicule législatif
d'une loi de finance rectificative pour
parler d'un énorme problème qui est
celui du travail et de la retraite mais
on retourne toujours sur les visions
alors mon collègue évoquait la situation
d'une personne je donne pas son nom 55
ans né en 68 elle a passé 8 ans sans
travailler pour élever ses quatre
enfants et a commencé à travailler à 20
ans avant la réforme ces 8 années sans
travailler étaient compensés par les 8
trimestres donnés par enfant pour les
enfants et par le congé parental elle
pouvait donc partir à 62 ans après la
réforme elle devra attendre 64 ans pour
partir à la retraite et elle perd la
surcote de 7 et demi pour cent dont elle
aurait bénéficié en travaillant jusqu'à
64 ans autre problème les temps partiels
souvent imposés dans les métiers
précaires ne sont pas du tout pris en
compte dans ce texte pour toute cette
saison nous demandons au gouvernement de
revoir sa copie
je présente l'amendement 3500 si vous
nous rejoignez sur l'antenne de Public
Sénat nous sommes lundi au cinquième
jour de l'examen de la réforme des
retraites au Sénat et à l'instant nous
venons de passer sous la barre des 3000
amendements qu'il reste à examiner d'ici
au 12 mars au Sénat de quoi parle-t-on
lorsque l'on parle de ses amendements et
bien en fait le gouvernement dépose un
projet de loi donc une réforme en
l'occurrence la réforme des retraites
qui prend ici et bien la forme d'un
projet de loi de financement
rectificatif de la sécurité sociale le
PLFSS r dont on parle depuis le début de
l'examen et bien à cette loi à ce projet
de loi elle vient s'ajoute viennent
s'ajouter des amendements donc déposer
par les sénateurs il y en avait au total
plus de 4700 certains ont été jugés
irrecevables car ils ne portait pas sur
une loi de financement la sécurité
sociale il y en avait au total 3700 au
début de l'examen et donc on vient de
passer sous la barre des 3000 j'ai en
même temps
synergie on l'a dit la durée requise
c'est vrai en général la durée requise
de cotisation touche de façon
différencielle tout le monde bien sûr
mais et plus et en général très
impactante pour les femmes à cause
justement de ces carrières hachées les
mesures d'allongement de l'âge
d'ouverture du droit à la retraite
touche en général tout le monde mais
plus particulièrement les catégories
socioprofessionnelles ouvriers employés
qualifié ou non qualifier
d'ailleurs est-ce que je voudrais dire
c'est que la synergie et bien
effectivement c'est les ouvrières les
employés femmes dans les métiers de
service qui elle en tant que femme si
vous voulez cette synergie vraiment
impact plus particulièrement nous en
reparlerons le 8 mars pour dire que
cette réforme
pour voilà pour dire que cette réforme
est une réforme quand le monde du
travail mais aussi contre les femmes
bien
dans le passé a demandé l'avis du de la
Commission à la vie du gouvernement je
vous l'ai signaler que je suis saisi de
deux demandes de scrutin public sur les
deux premiers amendements voilà monsieur
oui merci monsieur le président
je suis surpris de voir comme vous
devenez des adeptes de l'index senior et
des index en général
voyez-vous moi j'avais dit que j'étais
pas fan des index je vous l'ai dit dès
le départ bon à la rigueur l'index
Seigneur mais j'irai pas plus loin dans
dans les index voyez-vous et surtout
pour parler des carrières hachées je
pense que c'est pas un index qu'il faut
c'est les valoriser vous voyez je serai
plutôt sur le label pour les carrières
haché plutôt que sur les index mais ça
permet de rappeler un certain nombre de
choses parce que vous avez dénoncé à
juste titre mais ça a été dénoncé aussi
sur les bancs de la droite les
inégalités de carrière
effectivement c'est au cours de la
carrière professionnelle qu'il y a de
nombreux inégalités et elle se
traduisent après au moment de la
retraite c'est incontournable je vous
rappelle à ce propos là que c'est un
système par point les corrige pas
elles sont peut-être plus corrigées un
système paranéité que par un système par
point preuve en est c'est que les
agriculteurs nous ont demandé qu'on
calcule leur pension qui était sur un
système à points par des annuités ce qui
montre bien que les réformes de retraite
quelle qu'elle soit il y a tellement
d'inégalités sur le plan salarial sur le
plan des retraites qui se retraduisent
certaines sont gommés je vous rappelle
quand même que les montants de retraite
les différences de montants entre les
plus aisées et les plus pauvres sont
atténués par rapport aux différences de
salaires donc il y a un effet
redistributif à l'intérieur de notre
système paraît partition qui est
contributif qui gomme certaines
inégalités mais par contre
les différences qu'il est entre régime
peut en accentuer d'autres donc ça nous
a pas échappé qu'il fallait faire
quelque chose pour les carrières hachées
notamment pour les maires de famille
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
proposons un dispositif de surcote à
l'article 8 mes chers collègues
il est important il est important vous
qui êtes attaché à ces inégalités
notamment pour les niveaux de pension
notamment pour la prise en compte des
trimestres des maires de famille il est
important que nous puissions aller
jusque l'article 8 de faire en sorte que
quelque part dans nos débats on arrive à
s'entendre mais gagner un peu de temps
quand même parce que nos consignes rien
ont besoin qu'on amène
un peu plus de justice sociale au niveau
de cette réforme notamment avec les
maires de famille et ça peut être une
discussion qui peut les intéresser à ce
niveau là c'est la raison également pour
laquelle
nous avons pensé à travers ce dispositif
de prendre en compte les trimestres de
majoration qui ne seront pas
suffisamment brouillés en compte et je
réponds à Monsieur brolier parce que
dans l'exemple qui nous donne monsieur
Broly
si j'ai bien compris vous parlez d'une
mère de famille de trois enfants ce qui
veut dire cette mère de famille elle a
trois fois huit trimestres de
majorations en ce qui concerne la prise
en compte de ces maternités dans le
système privé par contre elle n'aura que
deux trimestres selon la date 2 à 4
trimestres puisque il y a une
modification dans le secteur public là
aussi c'est une inégalité c'est la
raison pour laquelle vous verrez qu'à
l'article 8 quand on parle de la prise
en compte des maires de famille avec des
majorations on met à une majoration
voyez-vous on n'a pas mis un nombre de
majorations parce que justement on
entretenait cette différence entre le
public et le privé qui méritera d'être
discuté c'est rapporté à des travaux du
corps compter sur modif Lubin et
moi-même pour faire en sorte que et
jean-marieberg qui fait partie du corps
pour faire en sorte qu'on soit attentif
à trouver des solutions parce que nous
considérons que ces particulièrement
inégalitaire et actuellement il y a déjà
dans le système de calculs de pension
20% de ces majorations qui ne sont pas
prises en compte ces maires de famille
qui pensent que leur majoration veulent
attribuer des points supplémentaires à
la fois pour le calcul de la durée leur
permettant derrière d'éviter parfois un
phénomène de décote ne sont pas pris en
compte à hauteur de 20% dans
l'augmentation de la durée d'âge ça
c'est un effet connexe on n'y peut rien
c'est 30% des majorations qui ne seront
pas pris c'est la raison pour laquelle
ça nous a interpellé que nous proposons
ce dispositif de surcote donc pour
conclure monsieur le Président on peut
pas gommer toutes les inégalités et nous
aurons encore des propositions à faire
dans ce domaine là merci
merci Monsieur le Ministre non très
rapidement monsieur le Président la
question des carrières hachées c'est
évidemment un vrai sujet et c'est vrai
que les carrières hachées se révèlent
encore plus au moment de la retraite
avec des pensions qui sont moins
importantes je suis pas convaincu que
l'outil index soit le mieux adapté pour
répondre à la question des carrières
hachées d'abord parce que si le salarié
est dans l'entreprise c'est bien que
l'entreprise en question permet de
réduire le côté haché de la carrière
puisqu'elle a recruté le salarié et donc
je vois pas je trouve ça un peu bizarre
d'aller pointer du doigt à l'entreprise
qui précisément lui permet aux salariés
d'être dans l'entreprise si c'est sur la
question des contrats courts madame
linmann je vous entendais m'interpeller
pour moi la question des contrats elle
est traitée en grande partie par le
bonus malus qu'on a mis en place sur les
cotisations des entreprises liées au
recours au contrats ça me semble
beaucoup plus efficace cette mesure là
que l'index donc pour ces raisons
défavorables merci
nous allons passer au vote explication
de vote madame Meunier est inscrite
je voterai les amendements proposés par
le groupe écologiste solidarité et
territoire
ça a été dit triple peine pour les
femmes et notamment donc les carrières
hachées alors bien sûr l'index c'est pas
l'alpha et l'oméga mais c'est un moyen
que l'on peut avec des critères bien
resserrés se servir pour contraindre
ceci dit je sais que c'est pas la
panacée et je vais vous donner un
exemple de ce qui existe dans l'index et
Gap pro égapro donne la note donc
égalité professionnelle entre les femmes
et les hommes donne la note de 92 sur
100 un groupe hôtelier là on peut dire
bravo quand on y regarde de près
l'indicateur 1 celui qui mesure l'écart
de rémunération entre les femmes et les
hommes par tranche d'âge et catégories
socioprofessionnelles abaisser passant
de 38 40 à 33 sur 40 donc l'écart a dû
augmenter en défaveur des femmes mais
cette baisse est compensée par une autre
dimension qu'on trouve à l'indec à
l'indicateur 5 et qui lui équilibre
entre le nombre de femmes et le nombre
d'hommes dans les 10 plus hautes
catégories de rémunération et là donc on
peut penser que cette entreprise a
embauché plus de femmes donc vous voyez
comment le diable se niche dans les
détails parce que plus de femmes mais
moins rémunéré et au total une bonne
note donc on peut faire dire ce que l'on
veut aux index et c'est pour ça qu'on
est très méfiant sur les index seniors
en rapprochant et en resserrant les
critères on peut peut-être avoir plus de
garanties
comme un amené je pense que les index
c'est vraiment pas la la panacée
néanmoins j'observe qu'on veut bien
mettre des index sur certains sujets et
pas sur d'autres et de ce point de vue
la précarité du salariat les carrières
hachées c'est quand même une des grandes
crises du monde du travail aujourd'hui
donc comme Madame chaque fois chers
collègues je me trompe de votre nom
c'est pas si je dois faire un blocage
pensez mange le fait cette proposition
avec ses collègues c'est une bonne
proposition parce qu'elle équilibre le
regard qu'on doit avoir sur la situation
mais monsieur le ministre
vous ne faites aucun vous n'avez pas du
tout l'intention de faire des progrès
pour réduire les carrières hachées
puisque en tout cas pour les femmes
puisque dans les simulations du corps
que vous avez et les données que vous
avez données on maintient le taux
d'activité des femmes en 2030 excusée du
peu à l'actuel taux d'activités des
femmes or le taux d'activité des femmes
il est lié aussi à la précarité des
emplois des femmes pas simplement
d'avoir un emploi c'est de équivalent en
place si je puis dire donc vous n'avez
aucune attention politique de faire
reculer la précarité dans pour les
métiers féminins puisque vous maintenez
le taux d'activité des femmes enfin
monsieur le rapporteur
j'adore votre proposition de dire on va
pas faire des Indes contraignants on va
faire des labels alors moi j'imagine
bien le groupe Airbus
ayant face à lui plusieurs
sous-traitants pour tel ou tel
activité dire ah ben non finalement
celui-là il est un petit peu plus cher
au moins cher mais il a quand même un
label Qualité
emploi du Seigneur donc finalement je
vais prendre de la mer donc franchement
les labels n'ont pas cette efficacité
monsieur Lecomte
remercie monsieur le Président Monsieur
Miss mes chers collègues je soutiendrai
bien entendu c'est c'est ces amendements
même s'ils ne constitue pas en eux-mêmes
des solutions aux difficultés indiquées
concernant les inégalités salariales en
particulier femme homme et des carrières
hachées toutefois si on veut avancer sur
le plan des résolutions c'est mieux de
les connaître de les chiffrer et de bien
les préciser donc ça son utilité je
regrette aussi que finalement dans cette
réforme même si le débat que nous avons
sur ces points montrent combien il est
important de pouvoir améliorer ces
dispositions à la fois pour permettre
des des meilleurs retraites mais aussi
pour mieux favoriser les carrières
longues et les carrières qui permettent
finalement de cotiser à la retraite mais
je voudrais aussi en tant que sénateur
représentant les Français établiors de
France parler des carrières Rachel
internationales
des membres d'un couple qui suivent leur
conjoint et qui se trouve en situation
d'avoir interrompu leur carrière des
réflexions sur ce sujet existe de la
même manière que dans plusieurs pays
européens vous avez la possibilité soit
pendant votre carrière
soit au moment de la liquidation de
votre retraite de partager ou de
transmettre à votre conjoint des
annuités ou des trimestres cotisés et il
me semble qu'une réflexion dans ce
domaine mais hériterait aussi d'être
pris en compte bien entendu ça ne serait
pas un avantage pour la les cotisations
à l'assurance vieillesse par contre pour
les personnes concernées ça permettrait
de limiter un certain nombre de
personnes qui aujourd'hui se trouvent
avec des guerrières hachées des
handicaps au moment de liquidation de
retraite parce qu'ils ont favorisé la
carrière de leur conjoint et je crois
que c'est quelque chose qui mériterait
d'être fait en tout état de cause sur
tous ces sujets on voit bien que c'est
pas à la va-vite que nous pouvons
résoudre ces problèmes mais bien dans un
vrai projet de loi de réforme des
retraites qui qui mettrait dans la loi
des accords entre partenaires sociaux
jelure elle
voilà pour ces débats sur la réforme des
retraites ce matin au sein de la Haute
Assemblée les sénateurs qui sont en
train actuellement de débattre et bien
d'une proposition d'amendement des
sénateurs écologistes pour créer un
index sur les carrières hachées dans les
entreprises un index carrière haché qui
ne fait pas l'unanimité même à gauche
c'est un temps socialiste sur un peu
sceptique sur la proposition de leur
collègue écologiste pour parler de ce
débat sur la réforme des retraites au
Sénat j'accueille Philippe mouiller
bonjour oui bonjour vous êtes
vice-président du groupe les
républicains au Sénat sénateurs des
Deux-Sèvres un mot sur la formation de
la matinée la majorité de droite et du
centre du Sénat à voter ce qu'ils
appellent le CDI senior c'est à dire un
contrat pour inciter les entreprises à
embaucher des salariés de plus de 60 ans
avec une exonération de cotisation
familiale pourquoi selon vous c'est la
bonne solution alors que le gouvernement
n'y est pas favorable alors d'abord nous
on souhaitait surtout apporter une
réponse à la question l'interrogation
regarde de la mise en place de l'annexe
senior l'index étant une information
mais absolument pas un outil adapté
suffisamment adapté c'est juste une
information et donc nous proposons ce
CDI seniors donc rappelons donc l'idée
c'est de permettre à une personne qui va
partir de 60 ans de pouvoir avoir un CDI
qui a une durée jusqu'à ce que ces
personnes-là est la totalité ses droits
à la retraite donc ça peut aller jusqu'à
70 ans qu'il a l'âge maximum voilà donc
l'idée c'est de pouvoir permettre à voir
un outil adapté pour faire en sorte que
les charges qui incondent souvent des
niveaux de célèbre plus élevé puisque
lorsqu'on est en fin de carrière soit
compensées pour les entreprises par une
exonération des charges familiales c'est
un outil supplémentaire on croit
beaucoup à cette opportunité il faudra
bien entendu d'évaluer mais il faut dans
tous les cas agir répondre alors le
gouvernement nous renvoie ce sujet là à
une future loi travail nous nous pensons
que il est d'actualité en parallèle de
l'index en parallèle de la réforme des
retraites de mettre en place cet outil
dans l'actualité dans le gouvernement
dit attention au coup selon le ministre
Gabriel Attal ça coûterait 800 millions
d'euros par an et ça assécherait
progressivement les finances de la
branche famille de la sécurité sociale
alors vraiment la droite est plutôt
rigoureuse sur les publics
le coût de l'assurance chômage pour les
seniors de plus de 2 milliards donc pour
nous on nous sommes persuadés que nous
aurons d'un côté certes des charges
supplémentaires et donc un impact pour
la branche famille mais de l'autre côté
un gain on regarde de de gain qui est
frais sur l'assurance chômage donc après
l'histoire de transfert de compte mais
on est en tous les cas certains que le
bilan global sera favorable pour les
finances publiques à moins sur la
journée demain Philippe mouillé grande
journée de mobilisation avec des
manifestations partout en France les
syndicats qui appellent à mettre la
France à l'arrêt et dans le même temps
les sénateurs vont continuer de débattre
est-ce que vous confirmez que les
sénateurs vont débattre de l'article 7
sur le report à 64 ans et bien demain
alors on va voir en fonction de
l'évolution parce que on perdue quand
même du temps donc pour l'instant ce
n'est pas encore gagné quand dans les
délais si on regarde le même rythme que
nous puissions atteindre l'article 7 dès
demain en tous les cas on sait que c'est
un une envie un souhait de l'opposition
sanatoriale de faire en sorte que on
puisse avoir au calendrier certainement
après les manifestations le débat sur
l'article 7 voilà donc nous verrons bien
nous nous sommes preneurs dans tous les
cas d'un débat le plus rapide que nous
allons le plus rapidement possible à cet
arc de 7 de façon à ce que clairement
une pion marquer nos positions et
enclencher ensuite les autres articles
du texte de loi voilà donc nous verrons
en fonction de du déroulé de la journée
de cette nuit et si le pays est bloqué
qu'il y a des manifestations records
dans tout le pays est-ce que ça pourrait
influer sur le vote des sénateurs alors
sur le vote des sénateurs je ne pense
pas forcément on regarde ce qui se passe
notamment au niveau national après c'est
une question qui est renvoyée au
gouvernement dans sa capacité à la fois
de discuter du dialoguer de sa méthode
de communication et nous verrons au
regard de ce qui se passe mais nous
sommes nous dans une logique vous
connaissez depuis le début c'est-à-dire
que ça fait 4 ans que nous avons une une
conduite qui est la même donc
aujourd'hui on va pas se déjger au
regard des manifestations même si on
entend le message et on comprend
également cette mobilisation parce que
ces rôles des syndicats aussi de réagir
au final vous pensez que le Sénat
arrivera au bout dimanche soir à minuit
au bout de l'examen de cette réforme des
retraites il reste encore 3000
amendements on n'a pas on a passé la
barre des 3000 ce matin oui oui je peux
pas vous répondre on le souhaite sur
tous les cas mais je suis pas certain ça
va vraiment dépendre du rythme voilà
donc à la fois on va voir comment on va
travailler quels sont les plages
horaires ou qui va tout vert quels sont
les négociations possibles quels sont
les outils aussi que c'était un peu
mettre en place justement à utiliser
cette Arsenal réglementaire pour
accélérer les débats on fera le point
mercredi matin mais peut-être qu'il sera
nécessaire sera nécessaire de le faire
dans tous les cas nous souhaitons nous
la majorité sénatoriale aller au bout du
texte un mot peut-être sur la qualité
des débats il y a eu des débats de très
bonne tenue ce matin alors que peut-être
ce weekend on avait une droite un peu
silencieuse face à une gauche voilà qui
était très très polices ça y est il y a
un vrai débat entre la droite et la
gauche au Sénat alors il y a un vrai
débat surtout parce que nous avons des
amendements ce week-end on avait surtout
des abandons de suppression de la part
de l'opposition X fois le même
regroupement enfin avec on voit bien une
volonté d'obstruction par le volume
d'amendement déposé ce matin nous étions
cette fois dans une défense de nos
proposaments puisque nous avons proposé
la mise en place de ce CDI senior donc
on est dans un débat différent et
quelque part à travers cette réforme on
retrouve un peu le le gérer le débat
gauche droite sur les fondamentaux merci
beaucoup Philippe mouiller d'être venu
sur notre sur notre plateau ici dans la
salle des conférences du Sénat on va
tout de suite aller dans la tribune de
l'hémicycle retrouver Quentin Calmet
Quentin quels ont été les temps forts de
cette matinée et bien vous le disiez
sans conteste l'information de la
matinée c'est l'adoption par le Sénat de
ce CDI senior voulu par la majorité de
la droite et du centre je vous redonne
le chiffre du vote 202 pour 123 contre
le Sénat adopté cette mesure qui est une
mesure nouvelle Alex figurez pas dans le
texte que les députés ont examinés
puisque c'est un apport de René Paul
Savary un peu le monsieur retraite du
Senna il est rapporteur de la branche
vieillesse du projet de loi de
financement la sécurité sociale il siège
au bord de la commission il a expliqué
explicité ce qu'il voulait faire avec ce
CDI il s'agit d'un CDI senior calqué sur
le principe des CDI de chantier pour une
mission de fin de carrière dans une
entreprise avec un temps de travail
adapté aussi des missions de tutorat
éventuellement et bien sûr en échange
des exonérations de cotisations famille
pour l'employeur pour encourager
l'entreprise a effectivement salariée
davantage de seniors cette mesure n'a
pas du tout convaincu la gauche écouter
l'accusation du socialistiane
chanterelle et la réponse de René Paul
Savary après écouter monsieur le
rapporteur Sabari vous aurez dû renommer
votre amendement l'amendement Medef
parce que c'est c'est une commande
directe du Medef cette mesure va dans le
bon sens à déclarer Eric chevet le
vice-président de la CPE
on n'est pas étonné de sa réaction parce
que avec ce CDI senior vous allez
permettre au patron d'être exonéré des
cotisations familles non je ne suis pas
asservie aux Medef à tel point que
j'accepte bien volontiers l'indicateur
je crois pas que ce soit le Medef qui
réclame l'indicateur mais permettez-moi
de vous dire que
j'ai des relations toujours respectueuse
avec les différents partenaires sociaux
voilà notre très rapide pour vous dire
que le gouvernement était contre cette
mesure notamment à cause de son coût 800
millions d'euros les débats qui
continuent derrière moi
2998 amendements encore à examiner Alex
merci beaucoup Quentin et donc
l'information de cette matinée c'est que
le Sénat a voté en faveur de la création
d'un CDI un senior avec une exonération
de cotisations familiale notamment pour
favoriser l'embauche des seniors c'est
la fin de cette émission spéciale ce
matin ici en direct du Sénat pour suivre
les débats sur la réforme des retraites
je vous donne rendez-vous à 14h30 pour
la suite des débats ce sera en direct
sur Public Sénat et puis également à
suivre sur public sénat.fr un très bon
journée sur Public Sénat
[Musique]